BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE IS CALLED SUPPORTER.
AND LET ME GO THROUGH A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING. ARE THINGS ABOUT
OUR PROCESS- AS BAD AS ANY OF
YOU THAT HAVE INTENDED THE
PREVIOUS SEVEN SUB COMMITTEE
MEETINGS NOW IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND- AND STILL ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO WE'RE
HOLDING THESE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. TODAY HERE IN THE
CAPITAL BOTH SENATORS MINIATURE
ABODES ARE PRESENT. BUT THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE TO YOUR COMPUTER
SYSTEM GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY TO STICK
FEEDBACK. AND I ASKED THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED USED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO ON MUTE POLICE SELECTOR ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS. WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTINCT DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFIED
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING- TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE IT'LL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN BUT I
WILL ANNOUNCES NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR. EXCUSE ME. 844-291-6364
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR
ONE SEVEN SIX OH NINE. REFER TO
OUR WEBSITE BOTHERED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS IF YOU
HAVEN'T USED IT BEFORE. AND
ONCE AGAIN YOU IF YOU'RE USING
THE TELECONFERENCE UNDER HALF
TO MUTE ANY OTHER DEVICES
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY SO
THERE'S NO FEEDBACK. OUR MAIN
MAINTAINED DECORUM AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS I'M
GONNA LIMIT TESTIMONY TO ONE
MINUTE TODAY. AND SOMETIMES
THEIR LAG TIME SO PLEASE HAVE
PATIENCE AS EVERYONE IS WORKING
TO BE HEARDAND WE WANT THEM TO
BE HEARD. THIS AS I MENTIONED
IS THE LAST OF EIGHT SCHEDULED
HEARINGS IN OUR REGULAR SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS. TO HEAR THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF SUB COMMITTEE
ONE. THE HEARING WILL BE
LARGELY INFORMATIONAL DESIGNED
TO ALLOW FOR DISCUSSION OF
ISSUES AND TAKE FEEDBACK TO
INFORM ACTIONS THAT WILL BE
TAKEN LATER IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS IN APRIL OR
MAY. IN TODAY'S HEARING. WE'LL
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
REGARDING. CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM AND THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND BEFORE WE
BEGIN ARE THERE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS SENATOR MEANT. YES
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
APPEARING TODAY A FEW WEEKS
BACK I RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD RESTORED
ONLY THREE PERCENT. OF THE TEN
PER CENT CARD FROM FUNDING FOR
THE UC'S AND CSU'S LAST YEAR I
EVEN AS OUR STATE UNIVERSITIES
HAVE FACED INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES FROM THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SOMETHING
CLEARLY HEARTENED TO SEE THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH PROVIDES A FULL
RESTORATION LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
CUTS AND ALSO SUPPORT OTHER
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES IN HIGHER
EDUCATION I WANT TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWTON APARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR RESPONDING
POSITIVELY DARK CONCERNS. THE
DEAL STRUCK BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR AND OUR LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP TO FULLY RSTORE
FINDING THE U. SEASONS YES USE
IS AN IMPORTANT VESTMENT IN OUR
STATE'S FUTURE PROSPERITY AND
SUCCESS. OUR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IS THE CROWN
JEWEL OF HIGHER PUBLIC AND IN
THIS COUNTRY. FOR OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS UC AND CSU
HAVE PROVIDED AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION
CALIFORNIANS. AND THESE
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
FOR OUR STATE SUCCESS NOT ONLY
BY EDUCATING MANY GENERATIONS
OF OUR LEADERS IN GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS SCIENCE LONG THE ARTS.
BUT ALSO BY INVESTING IN
RESEARCH THAT HAS BEEN SO
CRUCIAL TO OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THESE INVESTMENTS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH. WHETHER
IN THE FORM OF CORE FUNDING FOR
UC'S FOR STUDENT SUPPORT FOR
PROTECT PARTICULAR PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THE UC AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES ARE YOU SEE
PRIME. OUR INVESTMENTS IN OUR
FUTURE AND THEY WILL PAY
THEMSELVES OFF OVER MANY TIMES.
I LOOK FORTY HEARING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION YOU SEE L. A. O.
AND OTHERS TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR MAN
WE APPRECIATE THOSE OPENING
COMMENTS- WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
AND I NOTE FOR THE RECORD THAT
CENTER ROAD SHOW BOTH HAD NO
OPENING COMMENTS I'M NOT
PASSING HER OVER- AND WILL MOVE
TO ISSUE ONE. WHICH IS THE
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
WITH US TODAY. IS CATHY BOOTH
FROM WEST DEAD CHRIS FERGUSON
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PAUL STEEN HOUSE AND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
KNOW THERE ARE ALSO OTHER
PEOPLE ONE RESERVE. FROM THOSE
PLACES TO ANSWER QUESTIONS WE
DID AT OUR- TABLE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL SHEET FROM THE
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
PLANNING UPDATE. WITH THAT WILL
GO IN THE ORDER IN WHICH I
INTRODUCED PEOPLE WILL BEGIN
WITH KATHY BOTH OF WEST AND
WELCOME TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE HOW FAR WE'VE COME IN
THIS PLANNING PROCESS. SO WHEN
WE STARTED OUT SIXTEEN MONTHS
AGO WE HAD WANTED TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT WAS DEEPLY
PARTICIPATORY AND DESPITE THE
CHALLENGES THE PANDEMIC WE'VE
HAD MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE PLANNING
PROCESS REPRESENTING SIXTEEN
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES.
INCLUDING EDUCATION HEALTH
SOCIAL SERVICE AND WORKFORCE
RELATED ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AS A LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
FROM THE COMMUNITY REPRESENTING
THE INTENDED USERS OF THE DATA
SYSTEM. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS STRIKING TO ME IS THAT
EVERYBODY COULD HAVE TAKEN THE
OPPORTUNITY OF THE PANDEMIC TO
STEP BACK FROM THE PLANNING
BECAUSE THEY WERE ON THE FRONT
LINES. BUT INSTEAD EVERYBODY
REALLY DOUBLE DOWN BECAUSE THEY
SAW THE STATUS SYSTEM AS
PROVIDING WHAT THEY REALLY
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO RECOVER.
OF AS THEY'RE GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET
MORE PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE IN THE
REPORT THAT YOU RECEIVED IN
DECEMBER REALLY REPRESENT THE
BEST OF WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT HOW
TO LINK DATA AND MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO THE PEOPLE THAT
REALLY NEED IT TO INFORM
DECISION MAKING. WE HEARD THAT
NOT ONLY FROM NTIONAL AND
STATE EXPERTS BUT ALSO FROM
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY WE'RE
ABLE TO DO AN OUTREACH CAMPAIGN
IN THE FALL THAT REACH MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO
ARE HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE. OF THE
IDEAS THAT WERE PUT FORWARD
FROM THE WORKGROUP. THAT REPORT
THAT YOU ALL RECEIVED IN
DECEMBER IS ACTUALLY VERY
COMPREHENSIVELY COVERED ALMOST
EVERYTHING THAT WAS ASKED FOR
US. IN THE ORIGINAL AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION AND MOST OF THE
WORK THAT REMAINS IN THE
PLANNING- UNTIL THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR IS GOING O BE
FOCUSED ON TECHNICAL DETAILS
LIKE DATA DEFINITIONS. LEGAL
FORMS- SECURITY PAPERWORK THAT
THAT THE ALL THOSE THINGS WE
HAVE TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
FULLY KEPT PRIVATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS- AND SO YOU HAVE A
LOT OF WHAT YOU WOULD NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT THAT DATA SYSTEM.
THE OTHER THING HAPPENING THIS
SPRING WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT
IS FOR DOING WORK AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE. PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES AND
MESSAGING THAT'LL MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO
THIS IMPORTANT INFORMATION.
HAVING GOTTEN SO FAR THE WORK
GROUP IS RECOMMENDING A PROOF
OF CONCEPT THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO TEST OUT SOME OF THOSE
COMPLEX TECHNICAL AND PRIVACY
PROTOCOLS THE- BEEN DEVELOPED.
BY THE GROUP. TO MAKE SURE IT
WORKS WELL WHICH WILL HELP THE
SPEED THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
STARTING NEXT SUMMER- IF HE'S
ABLE TO GO FOR IT ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE WOULD ALSO BE UPDATING
SOME CORE SYSTEMS. YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO DELIVER SOME OF THE
THINGS LIKE THE DASHBOARD
SHOWING. K. TWELVE TO POST
SECONDARY OUTCOMES FASTER THAN
ONE YEAR- FINALLY I WANT TO
SHARE THAT THE TRAILER BILL AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FULLY
REFLECT THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE WORK GROUPS THE REALLY HAVE
A CUT OFF. PACKAGE LOOK AT IT
COME. FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WILL HOLD
ALL QUESTIONS TILL WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THREE PANELISTS NEXT
WILL GO TO CHRIS FERGUSON FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THURMOND CHRIS FERGUSON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES. A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OF WHICH THREE
MILLION IT'S ONE TIME. TO
SUPPORT THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM THIS REFLECTS THE
ESTABLISHMENT. OF THE OFFICE OF
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S. OR WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY-
THIS ALSO REPRESENTS FUNDING
WAR. SOFTWARE AND TECHNOLOGY
ACQUISITION. ADDITIONALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES PROPOSE.
AN ONGOING THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT
TO SUPPORT THE- COLLEGE AND
CAREER GUIDANCE INITIATIVE
WHICH IS ONE OF THE COMPONENTS
OF THE DATA SYSTEM. ALL THAT
THE ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS PUT FORWARD
BY THE- CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM WORK GROUP. AND VERY
SPECIFICALLY I THINK WITHIN
THAT LANGUAGE APPEARS TO HAVE
WHICH IS THE OFFICE OF THE
STAMP WHICH IS THE- FUNCTIONS
OF THE GOALS OF THE SYSTEM. AS
WELL AS A DISCOUNT WHICH IS THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE. OF FOR
THE PROPOSED ON. OFFICE AND A
GOVERNING BOARD THAT WOULD
OVERSEE THE DATA SYSTEM- IT'S
VERY COMPREHENSIVE AND IT DOES
ALIGN VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OF THE
WORKGROUP. I WITH THAT I WILL
LUCK CONCLUDE MY REMARKS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THEN WILL
MOVE TO POSTING HOUSING OF. THE
LA O'S OFFICE. IT MORE. CARE
LAYER. MEMBERS POLICY HOUSING
WITH THE ANALYSTS ARE. FIRST I
THINK MS BOOTH AND HER TEAM
SHOULD BE COMMENDED FOR LEADING
THE WORKING PROCESS MONTH AFTER
MONTH THROUGH. IN PERSON AND
VIRTUAL MEETINGS THEY
FACILITATED MANY DISCUSSIONS
ARE PRODUCED REPORT THAT OUR
OFFICE SEES IS A GOOD STARTING
POINT. FOR THE LEGISLATURE AS
IT BEGINS TO WEIGH AND THE MANY
PARTICIPANTS ON VARIOUS
COMMITTEES AND WORKGROUPS
ITSELF ALL SHE SHOULD BE
COMMENDED FOR THE TIME THEY-
PUT TOWARDTHIS EFFORT AND
THOUGHTFUL CONTRIBUTIONS TOWARD
THE PLANNING ACTIVITIES.
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL TO CREATE
AN INTEGRATED LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM OR CALIFORNIA IS IN LINE
WITH A LONG STANDING PRIORITY
SYSTEM COULD GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE MORE HOLISTIC VIEW
OF THE STATE'S EDUCATION SYSTEM
ALLOW POLICY MAKERS. TO MAKE
MORE INFORMED BUDGET POLICY
DECISIONS CAN ALSO BE USEFUL
TOOL FOR EDUCATORS. WE HAVE
SEVERAL HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS IS
LOOK WELL AS RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE AS IT.
REVIEWS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS BEGINS AT RISK
REVIEWING PROCESS. FIRST THE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM
CURRENTLY IS NOT BEING PLANNED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGIES PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE OR POWER.
WHICH IS THE STATE'S
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY. PROJECT
APPROVAL PROCESS SO THE POWER
PROCESS HAS MULTIPLE STAGES
EACH STAGE REQUIRES DEPARTMENTS
TO CONDUCT SPECIFIC PLANNING
RELATED ANALYSES SUBMIT IT SO
SHE DID PLANNING DOCUMENTS TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. AND COLLECTIVELY
THE PLANNING DOCUMENTS FROM THE
STAGES CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN FOR IMPLEMENTING A
PROPOSED I. T. PROJECT.
INCLUDING THE COSTS ESTIMATED
COSTS. ADMINISTRATION IS
INDICATED IT'S THEIR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE THIS
CRADLE TO CAREER LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM WILL USE THE POWER
PROCESS BUT IT'S UNCLEAR AT
THIS POINT WHEN THAT WILL
START. IN ADDITION IT'S NOT
CLEAR AT THIS TIME WHETHER
THERE WILL BE INDEPENDENT
PROJECT OVERSIGHT AND
INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION AND
VALIDATION OF THE PROJECT WHICH
IS TYPICAL FOR STATE IT
PROJECTS ME SERVICES HAVE NOT
BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
MINISTRATION AND IN THIS BUDGET
REQUEST. SO OUR FIRST
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CLARIFY WHEN
IT IT TENDS TO BEGIN USING THE
POWER PROCESS FOR THIS PROJECT
AND COMMIT TO PROJECT OVERSIGHT.
GIVEN THE STATE'S MIXED RECORD
WITH I. T. PROJECTS. R. FOR. I
THINK THE MINUTE HE CRITICIZED
THE STATE'S ATTORNEY PROJECTS
THERE WAS A MEDIA RETRIBUTION.
SEVEN YEARS ALSO SPECIFY
GRINCHES WHICH IS YOU ARE
MISTER STEVE HOUSING YOU FROZE
FOR ABOUT THE LAST THIRTY
MINUTES THE MINUTE YOU SAID THE
STATE'S POOR RECORD ON IT
PROJECTS YOU FROZE SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WISH TO PICK UP
YOUR TESTIMONY FROM THAT POINT.
SURE SORRY ABOUT THAT ACTUALLY
IN THE OFFICE SO THAT THE WIFE
I SHOULD BE GOOD. SO YEAH I
GIVEN GIVEN THE- THE MIX RECORD
OF WITH I. T. PROJECTS
LEGISLATURES SHOULD SPECIFY IN
STATUTE WHICH IS THREE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT MR FERGUSON
MENTIONED A REQUIREMENT FOR THE
PROJECT TO GO THROUGH THE
POLICY PROCESS STARTING WITH
THE PROOF OF CONCEPT THAT MS
BOOTH MENTIONED IT ONCE
APPROVED TO HAVE INDEPENDENT
PROJECT OVERSIGHT SO JUST BEING
VERY CLEAR AND LEGISLATION.
THAT THE PROJECT IS TO GO
THROUGH THE POWER PROCESS AND
SUBMIT TO INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION. WE WOULD NOTE THE
MINISTRATION CAN ESTIMATE THE
PROJECT THROUGH THE POWER
PROCESS NOW AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY CAN USE THE
PROJECTS FIVE PRIOR PLANNING
EFFORTS TO HELP YOU DECIDE
WHICH STAGE OF THE PROCESS THE
PROJECT SHOULD BEGIN SO. THAT
THE PROCESS WOULD NOT HAVE TO
THE PROJECT WOULD NOT HAVE TO
START FROM SCRATCH WITH
PLANNING. SO THE SECOND MAJOR-
PROJECT RECOMMENDED BY THE
WORKGROUP AND PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GUIDANCE
INITIATIVE OR C. C. GI. THE
CALIFORNIA GOLF COLLEGE GUIDES
INITIATIVE HAS A NUMBER OF
FEATURES DESIGNED TO HELP
STUDENTS PARENTS HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE COUNSELORS. YOUR
GENDER ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
FOUR DOES A GOOD JOB
SUMMARIZING THOSE FEATURES.
ANECDOTALLY SEARCHES THROUGH A
HANDFUL OF TESTIMONIALS WE KNOW
FROM SOME SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND
OTHERS WHAT THEY THINK ABOUT C.
C. GI. BUT WHILE THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED BASE FUNDING TO CCCI
FOR YEARS TO DATE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT PROVIDED
ANY FUNDING TO C. C. GI
SPECIFICALLY FOR AN INDEPENDENT
AND COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION.
NOR IS IT REQUIRED THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED C. C. G.
I. TO USE ANY OF ITS FUNDS THE
CON CONTRACT A CONTRACT FOR
SUCH AN EVALUATION. AS A RESULT
OF THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T KNOW
TO WHAT EXTENT AND HOW WIDELY
C. C. G. I.'S VARIOUS FEATURES
ARE ACTUALLY USED BY STUDENTS
IN SCHOOLS WHICH FEATURES
FEATURES OR SERVICES IN
PARTICULAR THEY FIND MOST
VALUABLE. IF CERTAIN FEATURES
ARE NOT WIDELY USED WHY NOT
GOOD MODIFICATIONS BEING MADE
TO C. C. GI IN THAT CASE SO
THAT FEATURES A MORE USEFUL FOR
STUDENTS. AND OTHER POTENTIAL
USERS. THE END OF ARE YOU
WISHING SHOULD LOOK AT WHAT IS
THE IMPACT OF C. C. GI ON
STUDENT OUTCOMES FOR EXAMPLE
OUR STUDENTS WHO UC C. GI
BETTER INFORMED ABOUT COLLEGE
ELIGIBILITY IN CAREER OPTIONS.
AND THEIR PEERS WHO DON'T USE
C. C. GI SO WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD HAVE THIS
INFORMATION. BEFORE EMBARKING
ON A MAJOR AND COSTLY EXPANSION
C. C. GI. INSTEAD OF PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR C. C. GI EXPANSION
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR WE
JUST RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE ONE TIME FUNDING FOR AN
EVALUATION. AND IN USE RESULTS
OF THE EVALUATION TO INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE'S NEXT STEPS. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT C. C. GI IS A
DISCRETE PROJECT SO TAKING TIME
FOR AN EVALUATION WOULD NOT
AFFECT THE OVERALL TIMELINE FOR
THE LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM
PROJECT. NOW TO MOVE UP TO
GOVERNANCE UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TWO THIRDS OF THE
GOVERNING BOARD WOULD BE MADE
UP OF DATA PROVIDERS. WE JUST
ONE THIRD CONSISTING OF PUBLIC
MEMBERS. DECISIONS MEANWHILE
WOULD BE MADE BY A TWO THIRDS
VOTE. WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HAVE MORE PUBLIC
REPRESENTATION ON THE GOVERNING
BOARD AS A WAY TO MITIGATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF DATA PROVIDERS
CONTROLLING THE DATA AND USING
IT PRIMARILY FOR SEGMENT
SPECIFIC INTERESTS. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE GIVEN THAT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THE GOVERNING BOARD WOULD BE
CHARGED WITH DEVELOPING THE
DATA REQUEST PROCESS USED BY
EDUCATION RESEARCHERS AND
OTHERS. HISTORICALLY SOME
SEGMENTS HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT TO
APPROVE A REQUEST. ENSURE THAT
DATA. WE ALSO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD HAVE MORE OF
A ROLE IN SELECTING MEMBERS OF
THE GOVERNING BOARD UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE
GOVERNOR WOULD. GET TO SELECT
FOR PUBLIC MEMBERS INCLUDING
TWO FROM THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM
WELL SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
COMBINED WOULD GET TO SELECT
JUST TO PUBLIC MEMBERS SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF NON DATA
PROVIDERS ON THE GOVERNING
BOARD SO THEY ARE AT LEAST
EQUAL TO IF NOT GREATER THAN.
THE NUMBER OF SEATS HELD BY THE-DATA PROVIDERS. WE FURTHER
RECOMMEND SPECIFYING. BROUGH
TRAILER LANGUAGE OTHER STATUTES
THAT THE NON DATA PROVIDING
MEMBERS INCLUDE REPRESENTATION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AS WELL
AS BIPARTISAN REPRESENTATION
FROM THE LEGISLATURE. ON THE
QUESTION OF WHO SHOULD BE
CHARGED WITH BUILDING HOUSING
IN OPERATING THE DATA SYSTEM WE
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S UNREASONABLE
FOR A NEW OFFICE WITHIN THE
OFFICE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY TO BE THE ONE TO IT KEEP
IT TO INCUBATE IN LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM. WELCOME BOB
DOESN'T HAVE ANY PARTICULAR
EXPERIENCE OR EXPERTISE WITH
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
IMPLEMENTING AND DATA SYSTEMS
IT IS WORKING TO IMPROVE HOW
THE STATE COLLECTS MANAGES AND
USES DATA THROUGH ITS STATEWIDE
DATA STRATEGY WHICH IS LED BY
THE CHIEF DATA OFFICER WITHIN
THE BOX SO WE THINK THERE ARE
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
CREATE SYNERGIES BETWEEN THAT
STATEWIDE EFFORT. AND WHAT'S
PROPOSED WITH THE STATUS SYSTEM.
THIRTY TWO ADDRESSED OF THE
FIRST SUGGESTED QUESTION ON
PAGE SIX OF YOUR AGENDA ASKED
ABOUT COST. WE THINK THE
ESTIMATED ONGOING COSTS OF
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR GOV
OPS LIKELY IS TOO LOW FOR WHAT
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO
DO. IN PARTICULAR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE LIST SOUTH
RESPONSIBILITIES AND REQUIRED
ACTIVITIES OF GOVERNMENT OF OPS
STAFF YOU CAN SEE ON PAGE FIVE
OF YOUR AGENDA SO YOU HAVE.
CREATING PROCURING MAINTAINING
SECURITY NEEDS TECHNOLOGICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM. ALSO
CREATING AND MAINTAINING PUBLIC
FACING FORMAL AND MULTIPLE DATA
TOOL SUPPORTING THE GOVERNING
BOARD ADVISORY BOARDS
SUPPORTING THE DATA PROVIDERS
BEING THE POINT OF CONTACT FOR
RESEARCHERS ENSURING LEGAL
COMPLIANCE AND IN ALL THESE
ACTIVITIES WOULD BE DONE AS
PROPOSED BY GOVERNOR WAS JUST
TWELVE STAFF WITHIN O BOX. NOW
THE WORKING GROUP'S DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
REPORT NOTES THAT OTHER STATES
TYPICALLY HAVE BETWEEN ELEVEN
AND THIRTEEN STAFF FOR THEIR
DATA SYSTEM. YET AS THE
WORKGROUP NOTES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SSTEM AS PROPOSED LIKELY
WOULD BE MORE COMPREHENSIVE
THAN THESE OTHER STATES WITH
MORE DATA PROVIDERS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE SYSTEM MORE
TOOLS FOR THE PUBLIC ACCESS.
AND NOT TO MENTION THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR HAVING TO
MANAGE TWO OTHER PROJECTS THE
C. C. GI AND HE TRANSFERRED
FORTY WHICH IS ALSO RECOMMENDED
BUT I TO WORK WITH. AND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S- TRAILER BILL.
LANGUAGE AS PROPOSED. SO
UPDATED. ON ON BECAUSE FOR
GOVERNOR. WELL AS DAVID FOR CC
IN THE TRANCE ARE EXPECTED IN
THE WORK GROUPS APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PROGRESS REPORT. THE
FINAL REPORT IS DUE LEGISLATURE
BY A JUNE. THE MINISTRATION HAS
INDICATED THAT SHOULD THERE BE
A REVISED FUNDING
RECOMMENDATION RECOMMENDATION
REFLECTED IN THAT REPORT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD
CONSIDER ANY REVISIONS TO ITS-
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
PART OF ME REVISION. SO JUST
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING AMOUNT COULD
CHANGE AND YOU COULD SEE. NEW
ESTIMATES ON OVERALL PROJECT
COSTS. LIKELY THAT WE KNOW
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
LASTLY AS AGENDA IS THE AGENDA
NOTES ON PAGES FIVE AND SIXTY
MINISTRATION HAS A CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET REQUEST TO BEGIN
SPENDING SIX MILLION DOLLARS
REMAINING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE'S ORIGINAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS APPROPRIATION
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
AND THE SIX MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM AS
WELL AS BEGIN EXPANDING AND
SCALING CCDI. AND HIRING SOME
SOME INITIAL PROJECTS THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING A RESPONSE
ADMINISTRATION BY APRIL
FIFTEENTH ON WHETHER IT CONCURS
ARE NOT WITH THE EXPENDITURE OF
THESE FUNDS FOR THESE PURPOSES.
THAT'S NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA. WE
UNDERSTAND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
DESIRE TO MOVE QUICKLY TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE OF THE
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
BUT GIVEN ALL THE IMPORTANT
DECISIONS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TO MAKE ON THE DIRECTION AND
SCOPE OF THE DATA SYSTEM. THE
UNKNOWNS AT THIS TIME ABOUT
ONGOING TOTAL PROJECT COST WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE HOLD
OFF COMPARING WITH THE CURRENT
YEAR EXPENDITURE REQUEST UNTIL
AT LEAST AFTER MAY REVISE AND
THEN MAKE IT. MORE COHERENT
DECISION AT THAT TIME AS PART
OF AN OVERALL FUNDING PLAN FOR
THEIR CRADLES GROUP DATA SYSTEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FROM. I
WAS GONNA ASK- CHRIS FERGUSON
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
RESPOND TO MR STEINHAUSEN BUT-
THERE WAS SUCH A LONG LIST OF
THINGS. THAT LET'S JUST NOTE
THAT HE MADE THOSE COMMENTS AND
I WOULD ASK MR FERGUSON IF YOU
HAD ANY GENERAL COMMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO THE L. A. O.'S
RECOMMENDATION. YEAH CERTAINLY
THANK YOU GOD GOD CHAIR LAYERED
UP- I THINK THERE ARE A FEW
TENTH CONTACT THE NUMEROUS
COMMENTS I THINK THERE. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS CERTAINLY
OPEN TO THE CONVERSTION
REGARDING ITS COVER ITS
PROPOSED GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE I
THINK WE HAVE HEARD THOSE
SIMILAR CONCERNS- AND WE ARE
OPEN TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS ANY OF
THOSE CONCERNS. I IT IS
ACCURATE TO SAY THAT THERE IS
AN APRIL FIRST REPORT THE WILL
BE FORTHCOMING FROM. OF THE
WORKGROUP THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY INCLUDE REVISED-
COST ESTIMATES FOR THE PROJECT.
AND IT IS. ACCURATE TO SAY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD REVIEW
THOSE CALLS I IN LIGHT OF THE
MAY REVISION- WE WOULD SAY
THOUGH THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE A FEW THINGS FOR EXAMPLE.
THE C. C. GI IT'S AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS PROPOSED
FOR USE WITHIN THE SYSTEM TO
PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TO OUR SCHOOLS AND
OUR PARENTS AND STUDENTS AT
SPECIFICALLY WE THINK THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO THAT
ASPECT. OF THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM- ADDITIONALLY I
REQUIRE PROVIDED THAT IN THE
OUT YEARS RIGHT NOW THE
ADMINISTRATION GOES PROJECT
SIXTEEN DIVISIONS. ARE STARTING
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AS OPPOSED
TO TWELVE POSITIONS OR OR IN
THE BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE AS
OPPOSED TO TWELVE POSITIONS IN
THE BUDGET HERE SO THERE. IS A
SLIGHT INCREASE PROJECTED IN
THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS THAT
WOULD BE. IT HOW. WITHIN THE
OFFICE- AND I THINK THINK
GLOBALLY WE WOULD JUST SAY
THAT. WE WANT PROGRESS TO
CONTINUE ON THE DATA SYSTEM WE
KNOW THAT THAT. MEANS BEGINNING
VERY EARLY I OR AT LEAST
PARTIALLY DESCRIBE THIS SCHOOL
YEAR USING FUNDS THE WERE
ALREADY APPROPRIATED INTENDED
FOR THIS PURPOSE I IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET-
I'LL- CERTAINLY. SEE THE VALUE
IN THE SYSTEM WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE THE TREMENDOUS
WORKER THAT'S GONE INTO. THE
DISCUSSION TODAY- AND WE NO
THAT THE SYSTEM HAVE ABOUT NOT
FOR. OUR INDUSTRY TO RE.
INTERPOL BY AS PER IT WOULD
ALSO ON TRIMMING BENEFITS. WERE
UP FOR PARENTS AND DROPPED. I
SERVICE A LOT OF VALUE IN THE
SYSTEM WE WANT TO CONTINUE
MOVING FORWARD WITH. THANK YOU
AND- I THINK WE WOULD JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE YOU WORKED WITH
THE L. A- TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES AS WELL AS THE
ONES WHERE. HE RECOMMENDED THAT
YOU WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADDRESS THEM HARBORONE LAST
RELATED QUESTION. ARE ASKING
HOW THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
REQUEST IT'S UNDER REVIEW BY
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. INTEGRATES WITH OF.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THAT'S THE FINANCE. DURING
THEIR TWO CORE COMPONENTS- ONE.
IS A PROOF OF CONCEPT A
COMPONENT. WHERE BY WORKING
WITH ATTEMPTING. LOOK AT SOME
OF THE SOFTWARE PACKAGES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO ENSURE THE
THING ON SOFTWARE PACKAGES AND
A TECHNICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WOULD FACILITATE THE TRANSFER
OF DATA. BETWEEN EIGHTEEN- IN
MEETINGS SO THERE'S A- I THINK
IT'S THREE SPECIFIC ENTITIES
THAT HAVE AGREED TO PILOT
CERTAIN DATA SETS THAT THEY
HAVE TO SEE THAT THOSE
EXCHANGES CAN OCCUR AND ARE
OCCURRING AS INTENDED. TO
SUPPORT THE DATA SYSTEM AND
THEN THE SECOND COMPONENT
PROBABLY THE LARGER COMPONENT
IS THERE ARE SOME RESOURCES
THAT ARE SET ASIDE FOR. FUTURE
SUPPORT OF THE PROGRAM FOR ONE
TIME COSTS THAT WOULD OCCUR AND
ALSO TO SUPPORT SOME TECHNICAL-
REVISIONS TO EXISTING SYSTEMS
TO HELP FACILITATE A
COMPATIBILITY WITH THE DATA
EXCHANGES SO A THERE WOULD BE
SOME SUPPORT FOR. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OR TECHNICAL
ARCHITECTURE IN THE CALVET
SYSTEM AS WELL AND SOME SUPPORT
FOR BEGINNING TO EXPAND- C. C.
G. I. IN JUNE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO SERVE MORE US SCHOOLS
STUDENTS. AND PARENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU BUT FROM- THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE. OUR
CHAU. I DO HAVE A QUESTION- AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW I AM A
FRESHMAN SENATOR I'M JUST KIND
OF CURIOUS AS TO THE COST OF
THE PROGRAM IS THAT PRETTY
STANDARD IN IN PROGRAMS THAT
ARE BEING OR SYSTEMS THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED IT. WITHIN OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. MINISTER AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ARAMBULA I'M GOING TO THIS ONE.
PROBABLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OKAY LET'S ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SURE SO THE COST OF WE
HAVE FOR THIS SYSTEM ARE
PRIMARILY- I ONE THE
OPERATIONAL ASPECTS AND TO THE
ACTUAL SYSTEM DEVELOPMENT SO
WITHIN THE SYSTEM DEVELOPMENT
OR THE ACQUISITION LARGELY OF
SOFTWARE SOLUTIONS THAT EXIST
TODAY- THAT WE WOULD BE
ACQUIRING. SHOULD THEN
IMPLEMENT AND USE FOR THE DATA
EXCHANGES BETWEEN THAT THE
SYSTEM IN THE SEGMENTS AND THE
ENTITIES PARTICIPATING IN THE
SYSTEM- WE THINK. THAT BECAUSE
THAT THE COSTS ARE LARGELY
SOFTWARE DRIVEN AND THEN
BUILDING OUT THE TOOLS TO
ENABLE- INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS
THAT DATA. WE THE COST FOR OUR-
IN LINE WITH WHAT WE WOULD
EXPECT WE WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING. I'M IN THE BACK
PROBLEMS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY- YOU
KNOW INITIALLY- SO CERTAINLY I
THINK WE SEE THAT- COSTS- AS
BEING. IN LINE WITH WHAT WE
WOULD EXPECT- BASED ON THE
ESTIMATES THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THE DATA SYSTEM
AND HOW WE ARE FACILITATING THE
EXCHANGES OF DATA. DID THAT
PERFECTLY YEAH OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANKS TO OUR
PANELISTS THAT COMPLETES OUR
DISCUSSION ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER
ONE. AND WE WILL NOT THERE ARE
A LOT OF ISSUES THERE AND WE
WILL NOT THEM AS WE HAD TO THE
MAIN REVISED. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO THE MAIN EVENT WHICH IS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE- OF THROUGH SEVEN ISSUES
ARE TWO THROUGH SEVEN AND WITH
CENTURY HAVE THE SAME PANELISTS
FOR ALL OF THEM- BRIAN RUTLEDGE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
REBEKAH KIRK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAY JEFF
BURTON AND FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA JASON CONSTANT
D'EUROS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND THE ONLY
VARIATION IS THAT MS CLARK WILL
NOT BE INVOLVED IN ISSUE SIX
BUT OTHER THAN THAT IT WILL BE
THE SAME PANEL SO WE'LL MOVE OF
THE ITEM TO WHICH IS THE BASE
BUDGET INCREASE AND PROBABLY
THE OVERVIEW OF BUDGETARY WAY
FOR UC AND WILL BEGIN WITH
BRIAN RUTLEDGE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. MORNING MY
COLLEAGUE REBECCA KIRK IS GONNA
START US OFF AND THEN I'LL
FINISH US OUT HERE THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MR SHARE THANK YEAR
REBEKAH CURFEW PARTNER FINANCE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
A 3% INCREASE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED THREE
POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING COMPRISED OF NINETY
FIVE MILLION FOUR UC CAMPUSES.
AND EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION
BETWEEN THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT THE UC PASSED A ROLL
ACCOUNTING KIND KEEPING AND
HUMAN RESOURCES DEFENSE AND THE
UC DIVISION. OF AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES. IN ADDITION
PART OF THE EARLY ACTION
AGREEMENT RECENTLY ANNOUNCED A
FINANCE LETTER WAS ISSUED TO
PROVIDE YOU SEE THREE HUNDRED
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONGOING. YOU SEE HAVING
COURAGE TO USE THESE RESOURCES.
FIVE SUPPORT FOR CAMPUS OF
CHANGING OPERATIONAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS. IN TOTAL
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THE
EARLY ACTION AGREEMENT WOULD
PROVIDE YOU SPEAK WITH FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONGOING.
BUDGET FEEDS THE AMOUNT OF UC'S
BASED GENERAL FUND REDUCTION IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE JACQUI.
IN ADDITION TO TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND RESOURCES.
3% BASE INCREASE PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
CONTINGENT UPON IT THAT I'VE
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. COLLEAGUE BRIAN
RUTLEDGE WILL OUTLINE THE
EXPECTATIONS. GOOD MORNING
BRIAN ROSE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO. THE OVERALL HIGHER
EDUCATION AGENDA FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S IS FOCUSED ON
EQUITY IN ACCESS. SO WITH OUR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. PROPOSE
BASED AUGMENTATION WORSE WERE
EXPECTED WORK PROVIDING FIVE
EXPECTATIONS THAT COME WITH
THAT THE FIRST IS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CREATED A DETAILED AND
ACTIONABLE EQUITY PLAN BY JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE PLAN WOULD DETAIL HOW THE
UC WILL. REDUCE EQUITY GAPS BY
TWENTY PERCENTAGE POINTS.
ANNUALLY AND ACHIEVE FULLY
CLOSING THOSE EQUITY GAPS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THIS WOULD
BE THE LANGUAGE WE HAVE.
REQUIRES ALIGNING TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ON DEFINING AND HAVING METRICS
FOR THOSE EQUITY GAPS. THE
SECOND MAJOR EXPECTATION IS
THAT THE UC. INCREASE IT ONLINE
CAPACITY. ABOVE THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ACADEMIC YEAR
LEVELS BY TEN PERCENTAGE POINTS.
SO THAT'S ESSENTIALLY IMPROVE
THE ONLINE CAPACITY OF THE PRE
COVERT SYSTEM TO RECOGNIZE NOW
THAT CODE IS HAPPENED AND WE'VE
GONE TO ALMOST FULLY ONLINE
WANT TO PRESERVE SOME THAT
CAPACITY. THE THIRD EXPECTATION
IS THAT THE UC. REALLY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE CREATES A
NEW TOOL OF MISSIONS PROGRAM.
THIS NOODLE MISSIONS PROGRAM
WOULD BE A STANDALONE
DISTINCTIVE TRANSFER PATHWAY.
BUT IT WOULD COMPLEMENT
EXISTING TRANSFER PATHWAYS. THE
WAY FIRST TIME FRESHMEN WOULD
BE ABLE TO APPLY TO A CCC WHILE
ALSO CON CURRENTLY APPLYING FOR
FUTURE ADMISSION TO THE UNIT TO
A UC CAMPUS OF THEIR CHOICE.
AND BASED ON SEVERAL CRITERIA.
A INCLUDING COMPLETING AN
EIGHTY T. OR AT T. LIKE
EQUIVALENT THROUGH THE UC
SYSTEM IN TWO ACADEMIC YEARS
THEY WOULD THEREFORE BE. HAVE
GUARANTEED FUTURE ACCESS TO UC
CAMPUS. THE GOALS THAT WE
SPECIFY FOR THIS DUAL MISSIONS
PROGRAM INCLUDE TO INCREASE
ACCESS FOR PERSONS AFFECTED
UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS.
STUDENTS FACING GEOGRAPHICAL
CONSTRAINTS ARE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. TO INCREASE
UNDERGRADUATE GRADUATION RATES
TO DO DECREASE STUDENT COSTS TO
IMPROVE TRANSFER PATHWAYS
OVERALL THROUGH THE STATE AND
TO INCREASE PREDICTABILITY FOR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR
INSTITUTIONS AND SEE ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS COME ONE SIX AGREEMENTS
ARE IN PLACE. ALSO CRITICAL
HERE IS THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
ACCESS AND EQUITY COMES THROUGH
IN THE DUAL MISSIONS PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE SPECIFY THAT YO SEE
SHALL TRY TO ROUGHLY A MINUTE
HALF OF UC ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
THROUGH THIS NEW. ADMISSIONS
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO HALF THAT
OUR- FIRST TIME FRESHMEN THAT
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE BE UC
ELIGIBLE IN THE FIRST PLACE
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY. TO ADDRESS
UNDERREPRESENTED AND
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS. THE FOR
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT TUITION
FOR RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES
REMAINED FLAT- THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ACADEMIC YEAR- THE
FIFTH IS THAT. YOU SEE WORK TO
BETTER ALIGN STUDENT LEARNING
OBJECTIVES WITH WORKFORCE AND
INDUSTRY NEEDS SO WITH THAT
WILL CONCLUDE OUR- OUR
PRESENTATION OF THE BASE
AUGMENTATION AND EXPECTATIONS
AND WE'RE OPEN FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. I KNOW AS
WITH THE PREVIOUS PANEL WILL DO
QUESTIONS WHEN OUR- EVERY
PANELIST IS PRESENTED WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO SEE JEFF BURTON
AND FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING SURELY
ARE TO MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND STAY OVER
CANADA AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA-
GRATEFUL FOR THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP
AND THE GOVERNOR FULLY RESTORED
UNIVERSITIES BASED BUDGET
REDUCTIONS STARTING JULY FIRST.
RECEIVING THESE FUNDS BACK IS
CRITICAL FOR AVOIDING STEEP
REDUCTIONS THE CAMPUS SERVICES.
THE RESTORATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY SPACE BUGET ALLOWS
US TO MOVE AWAY FROM CRISIS
MANAGEMENT WHICH COULD HAVE
MEANT HUNDREDS OF LAYOFFS
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. THIS
RESTORATION GETS YOU SEE BACK
TO THE SAME LEVEL OF FUNDING AS
IN THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL YEAR. NOW WE
CAN INSTEAD DISCUSS HOW DO
UNIVERSITIES POPULATIONS CAN BE
SUPPORTED AND EVEN ENHANCE TO
ALLOW OUR STUDENTS FACULTY AND
STAFF TO THRIVE AND USE THEIR
SKILLS TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION CALIFORNIA AND THE-
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC REFLECTS OUR UNIQUE
ROLE. OF RESEARCH EDUCATION AND
PUBLIC SERVICE IN THE STATE OF
WITH THINGS INCLUDING- TREATING
PATIENTS PROVIDING COVER
TESTING FOR THE COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING OUR CAMPUSES I'M
PROVIDING REMOTE INSTRUCTION.
EVEN THOUGH THE INITIAL MONTHS
OF CODE NINETEEN WERE
ECONOMICALLY STRAINING ON YOU
SEE OUR LEADERSHIP EXPRESSED A
STRONG DESIRE TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE EMPLOYEES WHILE
PRESERVING AND EVEN
STRENGTHENING OUR EDUCATION AND
RESEARCH ACTIVITIES. FROM THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THERE
WERE NO COVERAGE. RELATED
LAYOFFS AT UNIVERSITY. J.
UNIVERSITIES REAL BECAUSE
AMOUNT TO OVER THREE ONE. THE
FEDERAL FUNDING YOU SEE HAS
RECEIVED FROM THE TO FEDERAL
RELIEF BILLS PASSED SO FAR
PROVIDE TO SPEAK WITH ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION OR ABOUT HALF OF
THE COST TO DATE. IS
SIGNIFICANT COST MEANS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY FACES BREAK
FINANCIAL PRESSURES AND MAKES
THE BASE BUDGET RESTORATION
CRITICAL IN AVOIDING FUTURE
LAYOFFS. WE'RE ALSO VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF GOVERNOR NEW
SINCE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHICH PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS UC STUDENTS. WE
WILL DISCUSS SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS IN GREATER DETAIL IN
THE LATER IN THE HEARING BUT
RIGHT NOW ALL FOCUS ON THE BASE
BUDGET GROWTH FUNDS. REVERTED
CALIFORNIA NEEDS HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION. THIS IS STAIN CORE
OPERATIONS IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. IS
FUNDS ARE NEEDED TO PAY COSTS
THAT COME FROM BEING A PEOPLE
DRIVEN INSTITUTION. BUT JUST A
MANDATORY COMPENSATION
INCREASES TO REPRESENT LABOR
ADDITIONAL RETIREMENT COSTS AND
HEALTHCARE COST INCREASES. THE
NEW FUNDING IS NOT RECEIVED
UNIVERSITY WILL NEED TO FIND
OTHER WAYS TO COVER THESE
COSTS. SUCH AS CUTTING EXISTING
SERVICES. EVERVERSE BUDGET
INCLUDES HUNDRED FOUR MILLION
IN NEW FUNDING FOR CORE
OPERATION INCREASES AND WE'RE
REQUESTING YOUR APPROVAL OF
THESE BONDS. ARE TIED TO THE
ACHIEVEMENT OF POLICY GOALS
THAT ARE DISCUSSED IN YOUR
AGENDA AND BY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST NOW- TO GET OVER
USED THE UNIVERSITY SHARES THE-
STATE'S GOALS OF ACCESS AND
INCLUSION. WE DO HAVE REQUEST
REGARDING TWO OF THESE PROPOSED
POLICY CHANGES. ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OUTLINED GOALS IS TO
REDUCE GRADUATION GAPS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM ALREADY
HAS A STRONG GRADUATION RATE OF
88% OR FRESHMAN ENTRANCE OFF
FOR SIX YEARS. AN 89% OR
TRANSPARENT TRENDS AFTER FOUR
YEARS. BUILT WE RECOGNIZE
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY FOR
IMPROVEMENT. THE UC REGENTS ARE
DEEPLY COMMITTED TO EQUITY AND
INCLUSION IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM. AND WITH
THESE GOALS IN MIND APPROVED
THE FRAMEWORK TWENTY THIRTY
PLAN. THIS PLAN SEEKS TO CLOSE
GRADUATION EQUITY GAPS AT UC BY
TWENTY THIRTY THE FIRST YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PLAN WAS
ESTIMATED AT SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS. WE'RE IN THIS ASPECT
UNDERTAKE THE WORK OF CLOSING
GRADUATION EQUITY GAPS BUT
CANNOT. DO SO WITHOUT NEW
RESOURCES. GO OUR EFFORTS OF
CLOSE GRADUATE GAPS HAVE NOT
THE BIGGEST FUNDED WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE 20%
INCREASING GRADUATION RATES
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. I REQUEST THAT FOR YOU
SEE WE BOTH RECEIVE NEW FUNDING
FOR THIS EFFORT AND THE
TIMELINE BE ADJUSTED BACK TO
TWENTY THIRTY. ANOTHER POLICY
GOAL PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
IS TO INCREASE YOUR ONLINE
COURSES BY 10% OVER EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY STUDYING
DEFECTIVE LESSEN CHALLENGES OF
REMOTE INSTRUCTION. INITIAL
INDICATORS ARE THAT REMOTE
INSTRUCTION HAS NOT BEEN
EQUALLY BENEFICIAL FOR ALL
STUDENTS. WE REQUEST TIME TO
COMPLETE OUR ANALYSIS BEFORE
DECISIONS ARE MADE AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT SHIFTING TOWARDS
ONLINE EDUCATION. THE
GOVERNOR'S LANGUAGE ESTABLISHES
10% INCREASE TARGET WITHOUT
PROVIDING NEW FUNDING FOR
COURSES WHICH WOULD MEAN NOT
ADDING TO THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
COURSES OFFERED BY SHIFTING THE
EXISTING COURSES THE ONLINE
PEDAGOGY. THAT HAVING BEEN SAID
WE DO SEE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INCREASING ONLINE COURSE
OFFERINGS AS A WAY TO SEARCH
STUDENTS- SUCH AS DURING SUMMER
WHEN STUDENTS ARE RETURNING
HOME WITH THEIR PARENTS OR
TRAVELING OR DURING THE
ACADEMIC YEAR TO ALLOW STUDENTS
TO PICK AN INTERNSHIP AT
ANOTHER LOCATION. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY MAKING ACADEMIC
PROGRESS. WELL WE SEE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE EXPANSION
OF ONLINE EDUCATION WE MUST
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
NOT ADOPT THE SPECIFIC TARGET
TIME. AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS A UNIQUE MISSION
INCOME- IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS WITH
RESEARCH INCORPORATED WITH
EDUCATION AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
WE EDUCATE OVER TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
WE EMPLOY NEARLY HUNDRED AND
SEVEN THOUSAND FACULTY AND
STAFF. OF WE CONTRIBUTE EIGHTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY ANNUALLY.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FACULTY BRING IN OVER FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
RESEARCH GRANT FUNDS TO
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR THAT'S
MORE THAN THEIR SALARIES- AND
THEY PRODUCE FOR INVENTIONS
THAT DATE THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S KNOWLEDGE ECONOMY.
AND FUEL THE STATE'S GROWTH IS
A WORLD INNOVATION LEADER YOU
SEE STUDENTS BENEFIT FROM THE
CUTTING EDGE INSIGHTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDED BY BEING
TAUGHT BY WORLD CLASS FACULTY.
WE ARE REQUESTING THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE RESTORATION AND
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YOU PROVIDE
THE UNIVERSITY WITH EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND ONGOING
FUNDING FOR CAMPUS OR OPERATION
COST. AND EQUITY EFFORTS. TO
CLOSE THE GRADUATION CAP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. ADDRESSING
CONSTANT TORRES LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THIS ISSUE
REALLY HAS TWO COMPONENTS TO IT
THE FIRST COMPONENT IS HOW MUCH
BASED FUNDING TO SUPPORT TO
PROVIDE THE UNIVERSITY. IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND THE
SECOND ISSUE IS WHAT
EXPECTATIONS TO ATTACH THAT WE
SUPPORT WELL TOUCH ON EACH
COMPONENT. ON THE FIRST ISSUE
OF HOW MUCH BASED SUPPORT BY
THE UNIVERSITY I'M ALWAYS TO BE
FEBRUARY AGREEMENT IN PLACE
WHICH RESTORES THE REDUCTIONS-
ENACTED AND IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. THE ISSUE BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IS WHETHER IT WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING OR MODIFICATION I'M
BEYOND THIS FEBRUARY
GREENLAND'S. ON THE ONE HAND-
AS- ARE YOU SEE NOTED IN
TESTIMONY ON THE UNIVERSITY IS
FACING ON SOME COST PRESSURES
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. SUCH THAT
IF THE LEGISLATURE WORK WERE
INTERESTED IN RETURNING TO
SERVICE LEVELS PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. SOME AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING COULD
POTENTIALLY BE WARRANTED. ON
THE OTHER HAND AS WE'VE NOTED
AND MANY OTHER- HEARING BEFORE
YOU THE STATE GENERAL FUND. ON
THIS PROJECTED TO HAVE DEFICITS
IN THE OUT YEARS AND- HAS
SOMEWHAT LIMITED CAPACITY. FOR
SUPPORTING MORE ONGOING
PROPOSALS. SO THESE COMPETING
FACTORS IN MIND WE RECOMMEND
THAT YOU REVISIT THIS ISSUE IN
NAY REVISION- WE GET MORE
INFORMATION ON THE STATE'S
BUDGET CONDITION. AFTER THE
SECOND COMPONENT WHAT
EXPECTATIONS TO ATTACH TO THE
BASE SUPPORT FOR YOU SEE. ON
OUR ASSESSMENT OF EACH OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
EXPECTATIONS STARTS ON PAGE
FIFTEEN OF YOUR GENDER AND ARE
YOU ACTUALLY HEARD A LOT OF OUR
COMMENTS ALREADY ON IN YOUR CSU
HEARING ARM IF YOU MIGHT RECALL
WE RECOMMEND SOME.
MODIFICATIONS TO THE-
EXPECTATION FOR EQUITY PLANS WE
RECOMMEND A MORE SIGNIFICANT
MODIFICATION. TO THE
EXPECTATION FROM MINE EDUCATION
EFFECTIVELY- ELIMINATING THEM
PROPOSED TEN PERCENT. INCREASE
IN HORSES AND INSTEADGETTING
SOME MORE INFORMATION TO A
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME I KNOW YOU HAVE A
BUSY AGENDA I'LL DEFER TO THAT
CUBAN YOU WOULD LIKE. FURTHER
DETAILS ON THAT. WHY PROPOSAL
IT BECAME I WANTED TO. I'LL
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON IS THE DOOR
EXPECTATIONS YOU MIGHT RECALL
IN OUR CSU HEARING THAT WE
NOTED THAT THE TRAILER BILL HAD
JUST BEEN RELEASED AND WE WERE
STILL AT THE MOMENT BUT WE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL. AND IN
OUR ESTIMATION OF THAT THE
TRAILER BILL STILL LEAVES MANY
CRITICAL DETAILS I'M ON
ANSWERED FOR EXAMPLE IT'S STILL
UNCLEAR HOW MANY STUDENTS WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE NEW
ADMISSION POLICY ALSO UNCLEAR.
EXACTLY WHICH TYPES OF STUDENTS
MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE IMMIGRATION
POLICY SO IT'S HARD TO GAUGE
THE POTENTIAL EQUITY IMPACTS OF
THE PROPOSAL IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR
HOW THE PROPOSAL WOULD INTERACT
WITH ON SOME OF UC'S EXISTING
PATHWAYS FOR EXAMPLE- UC
CAMPUSES ALREADY OFFER A
TRANSFER ADMISSION GUARANTEES
TO CERTAIN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. WHEN THIS PROPOSAL
ELIMINATE THIS PATHWAY OR WORK
IN TANDEM WITH THAT THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS WE DON'T
HAVE ANSWERS TO AT THE MOMENT
AND WITHOUT THIS INFO I'M IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SAY WHETHER THE
DEMOLITION POLICY WOULD BE AN
IMPROVEMENT TO THE TRANSFER
PROCESS OVERALL OR DO WE JUST
SIMPLY ADD TO THE COMPLEXITY BY
JUST ADDING ANOTHER PATHWAY
AVAILABLE. TO HAVE A CERTAIN
PORTION OF STUDENTS. I THINK
YOU GUYS ARE COMMON BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANYTHING AND HE MAY.
THANK YOU MUCH TO ALL THE
PANELISTS. LET ME BEGIN WITH
COUPLE OF. AND MAYBE STICKING
WITH THE L. A. L. JUST ONE OFF.
OF STICKING WITH THE L. A. O.
IF YOU COULD HELP ME BRIEFLY
JUST WITH THE LINEAR- WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE BUDGET BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S REFERRED TO ONE
PIECE OF IT. IS IT BASICALLY.
THE YEAR PRE COVERED WAS AT A
CERTAIN LEVEL THE FIRST BUDGET
TOOK IT DOWN DRAMATICALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
RESTORED AT PARKWAY THE
FEBRUARY AGREEMENT RESTORES IT
BACK TO THE LEVEL OF WHERE WAS
PRIOR TO COVERED AND THERE'S A
FEDERAL. OUR OUR STIMULUS MONEY
THAT'S BEEN RECEIVED BY UC THE
WORD IS IT ACTUALLY STAND IS IT
IS A AT THE SAME PLACE WITH NO
COST OF LIVING INCREASE SINCE
PRIOR TO COVERED OR IS IT
RESTORED TO THE SAME PLACE PLUS
THE COST OF LIVING INCREASE
PLUS THE FEDERAL STIMULUS. YEAH
THAT WAS THAT WAS A VERY
ACCURATE SUMMARY OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT PACKAGES BEFORE YOU
AND I APPRECIATE IT IS A LITTLE
HARD TO TRACK ALL THE DIFFERENT
PACKAGES- SO YOU'RE CORRECTED
THAT- THE- BUDGET LAST YEAR
ENACTED SOME REDUCTIONS TO
UC'S. BASED GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT- ACCORDING TO
LEGISLATIVE STAFF BE SEPARATE
GRAHAM AND THAT'S FAR. HAS
EFFECTIVELY RESTORES THESE
REDUCTIONS SO UC'S BASED
SUPPORT WILL BE RETURNED. TO
THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT IT HAD IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY SO PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC. AND THAT'S
WITH NO GOOD NO COLA- MARIN-
STANDING AS THE AS THE
AGREEMENT SO FAR IT'S JUST
RESTORATION LOCAL LAW NOW THE-
ADMINISTRATION IF YOU RECALL IN
JANUARY. DID PROPOSE- CERTAIN
AUGMENTATIONS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATES THAT
THESE AUGMENTATIONS ARE STILL
ON THE TABLE SO IF YOU GET IT
AT- LEGISLATURE WATER WITHOUT
THESE AUGMENTATIONS ON TOP OF-
THE RESTORATION THERE WOULD BE
A COLA FOR THE FOR YOU SEE IN
THE BUDGET YEAR- JUST LOOKING
AT THE NUMBERS YOU WOULD BE
SOMEWHERE AROUND THREE PERCENT-
OF- OF A COAL OUT OF ABOVE PRE
CANDIDATE GLOBALES QUE TEM LET
ME YEAH LET ME ASK THE UC
REPRESENTATIVE A QUESTION HOW
DOES THISSINCE THE STIMULUS
MONEY GOES DIRECTLY TO YOU HOW
DID THE STIMULUS MONEY RELATE.
TO ALL THIS. A WHAT CITY FOR.
THE STIMULUS MONEY WAS USED ON
CAMPUSES- TO HELP COVER LOSSES
FROM KOBE NINETEEN THE NEXT
ORDINARY COSTS THAT THE CAMPUS
IS CHAD- OUR CAMPUSES HE DATE
HAVE HAD ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF LOSSES FROM
KOBE- THAT INCLUDES DIRECT
EXPENDITURES AND LOST REVENUES
AND OUR HOSPITAL SYSTEM HAS HAD
ANOTHER- ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOSSES DUE TO CODE
RED. SO THE FEDERAL STIMULUS
FUNDS HAVE GONE TO- COVERED
THOSE- EXTRAORDINARY
EXPENDITURES AND HOW MUCH WERE
THE FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
COMBINED FOR BOTH OUR CAMPUSES
AND THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM SO OUR
HOSPITAL SYSTEM HAD ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION AND
EXPENDITURES AND RECEIVED EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION IN
CODE STIMULUS FUNDS- THE CAMPUS
SAYS RECEIVED ABOUT. THREE
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION IN
STIMULUS FUNDING AND THE
REMAINDER WENT TO STUDENTS- AND
SOMEONE TO OUR NATIONAL
LABORATORIES AND IF I DID THE
MATH OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
OBVIOUSLY THE STIMULUS FUNDS
DID NOT MAKE UP THE INITIAL
LOSS THAT YOU SAID YOU'D HAVE
BOTH OF THE HOSPITALS AND UC
FROM COVERED. HOW DOES CORRECT
HOUSE REST. OF IT MADE UP- WELL
DO YOU- TO OUT A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR LOAN LAST SUMMER
TO HELP US COVER COST- WE TOOK
OUT ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR LOAN LAST
NOVEMBER- TO HELP WITH-
LIQUIDITY ON OUR CAMPUSES- WE
ARE ALSO USING. FOR OUR CAMPUS
CORE OPERATIONS WE HAVE BEEN
USING A VARIETY OF. COST
CONTAINMENT MEASURES INCLUDING
USING RESERVES WE HAD AN ALMOST
COMPLETE HIRING FREEZE- WE
LIMITED ALL TRAVEL. AND TOOK
SOME OTHER- ONE TIME COST
CONTAINMENT MEASURES. BUT IN.
THE STIMULUS MAKES UP. SOME
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
LOANS AND ALLOWED SET TO BE
PAID BACK IS THAT CORRECT. BUT
WE ARE STILL HOPING FOR FURTHER
FEDERAL STIMULUS AND I MEAN THE
EXISTING STIMULUS THAT YOU'RE
GETTING SOUNDED LIKE IT WAS TWO
THIRDS OF THE REDUCTIONS YOU
HAD FROM COVERED IN SOUNDS LIKE
THE LOAN. WAS VERY SIMILAR TO
THE AMOUNT OF REDUCTIONS YOU
TAKEN FROM COVERED SO WOULDN'T
A STIMULUS ALLOW YOU TO PAY
BACK PART OF THE LONG. NOPE
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE. A LOT OF
EXTRAORDINARY COSTS ON THE
CAMPUSES SO THAT FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS HAVE PROVIDED US
WITH ABOUT HALF. OF OUR CODE.
AND WENT TO DIRECT WENT TO
COVER DIRECT EXPENDITURES WELL
LET. ARM ALL OF WHICH WERE
STILL BEHIND SIR- WELL NO I GET
FROM FROM EVEN WHAT YOU SAID
YOU'RE STILL BEHIND BUT I THINK
THAT NONE OF THIS WAS SORT OF
CLEAR IN OUR MATERIALS AND AS
WE HEAD TOWARD THE MAY REVISE
IT WOULD BE REALLY NICE TO HAVE
SOME CLARITY ON THIS. SO THAT
IF WE WORK CONSIDERING
ANYTHING. UP FOR YOU SEE WE
HAVE THE FULL CONTEXT FOR.
RIGHT I THINK I THINK YOU'RE
STOP- IT DO A REALLY GOOD JOB
EXPLAINING WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
ACTIONS HAVE BEEN- WITH ALL OUR
COVERT LOSSES ARE MANDATORY
COURT COSTS GROWTH ARE. FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS COMING IN. UP
FOR D. TWENTY TWENTY. HELLO
THERE YEAR YOU SEE WAS STILL
ARE I KNOW THE STAFF DID A GOOD
JOB I. EAT IT BUT IT STILL LOOK
LIKE YOU HAD TO PULL UP TO THE
TOP TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT
THE- THE LINEAR- BALLOT SHE WAS
THE END SO THAT'S THE THING
THAT. WOULD BE NICE TO BE CLEAR
ON THIS WEEK WE. HEADED TO- MAY.
THE N. I. C. FROM FINANCE JUST
BEEN ALL THE WHITE I DON'T KNOW
IF YOUHAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR WE JUST TAKE THE
NODS FOR- WHAT THEY MEANT TO BE.
YEAH I THINK IT'S- TIME WE WILL
HAVE. CAN QUICKLY RESPOND TO A
UC RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF OUR
PROPOSED EXPECTATIONS I WOULD
JUST NOTED A HIGH LEVEL THAT.
WE'RE PROPOSING SOME
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES THAT ARE
OVER AND ABOVE WHERE YOU SEE A
EXPECTED TO BE. IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
WHERE PEOPLE AND OTHER STATES
ARE CUTTING HIGHER EDUCATION
BUDGETS THIS IS A DRAMATIC
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT JUST. NOT
CUT BUT TO DO MORE THAT THAT'S
ACTUALLY SOMETHING IS POSSIBLE.
THE UC IS A CRITICAL
INSTITUTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TRAINS THE WORK
FORCE DOES THE RESEARCH THAT
MAKES THE ECONOMY MOVE FORWARD.
AND GIVEN THAT THAT IT IS SUCH
A SUCCESSFUL INSTITUTION WE DO
THINK THAT THEY HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT OUR
PROPOSED EXPECTATIONS INCLUDING
REACHING THE TEN PERCENTAGE
POINTS GREATER ONLINE CAPACITY
ABOUT THREE COVERED LEVELS. THE
INCLUDING REACHING THE EQUITY
GAPS WHICH THIS IS THE TIME TO
MAKE EXTRA EQUITY A CENTRAL
INSTITUTIONAL FOCUS. THE L. A.
ALSO RAISED A CONCERN ABOUT. BY
THE ONGOING NATURE OF OUR
PROPOSED BASED AUGMENTATIONS
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT. THAT
BECAUSE THE UC IS A IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE HIGHER
EDUCATION IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
STATE THAT'S WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMING FROM
AND- BECAUSE IN THESE ONGOING
RESOURCES. AT THE OTHER NOTE IS
THAT YOU SEE IS NOT. ONLY MADE
UP SOME OF THE COVERT EXPENSES
AS NOTED BUT THE SIGNIFICANT
THE BIGGEST PORTION OF THOSE
CAME FROM AUXILIARIES AND FROM
HOSPITAL COSTS SO DO YOU SEE
BUDGET HAS A COMPLEX THERE'S
COMPLEX IMPACTS ON IT FROM KOBE
AND- IN OUR OUR EMPHASIS ON
UNDERGRADUATE AND- GRADUATE
EDUCATION AND OTHER. OTHER
STATE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE MORE COMPLEX
BUDGET WE DO THINK THESE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING. PROVIDE THEM
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES ENOUGH TO
DO WHAT OUR EXPECTATIONS
PROPOSED AND- TO ADDRESS THEIR
OTHER COSTS SO. HOPEFULLY THAT
WAS A COVERED A LOT OF THINGS
IT DID AND LET ME FOLLOW UP
WITH THE UNIVERSITY ON JUST. A
AND THEN BACK TO FINANCE ON ONE
LAST QUESTION AND I'M SURE. MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS A. N.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY NOW THAT.
ARE OF THE RESTORATION IS BACK
DOES THAT IMPACT ANY POTENTIAL
FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO TUITION
INCREASE. IT RESTORATION GETS
US BACK TO THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY- THIS SCHOOL
YEAR FUNDING LEVEL. OVERSEE
STILL HAS MANDATORY COST ROSE
UP FOR THE CURRENT YEAR AND FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR- FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR COST GROWTH IS
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
MILLION AND FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
IT'S HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION- THOSE
COSTS NEED TO BE COVERED WE'RE
HOPING THAT THE STATE WILL
COVERED THE BUDGET YEAR
MANDATORY COST GROWTH AND WE
INTEND TO COVER. OF THE CURRENT
YEAR COST GROWTH THROUGH
INTERNAL CUTS. BUT IT TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR
WILL STILL HAVE MORE POTENTIAL
COST GROWTH OF MORE ENROLLMENT
AS THOUGH WE ARE AT THIS POINT
NOT WANTING TO COMMIT THE
REGION'S TO ANY PARTICULAR
ACTION ON TUITION- YEARS FROM
NOW WE THINK THAT THAT IS A
CONVERSATION WE HAD WITH THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING
UNIVERSITIES FUNDING- BUT WE DO
WANT TO PROVIDE THE UNIVERSITY
WITH STABLE FUNDING SOURCES- IF
WE- HAVE. STEADY FUNDING
INCREASES OF WEEKEND THEN
COVERED THE COST AND- PROVIDE
SERVICES TO ALL OUR STUDENTS
MAKING CERTAIN THAT THE CURRENT
STUDENTS RECEIVE THE SAME KIND
OF SERVICES. THAT GENERATIONS
BEFORE THEM DID. MORE WHILE I'M
VERY GRATEFUL AS ONE OF THE
GENERATIONS BEFORE THAT
HAPPENED ABOUT LET ME ASK ONE
FAR FROM UP TO YOU AND THEN
BACK TO FINANCE YOU KEEP SAYING
MANDATORY INCREASES A LOT OF
THOSE ARE ACTUALLY NEGOTIATED
DROPPED- THAT IS CORRECT SIR
WE- DO NEGOTIATE WITH ARTS
IMPLEMENTED. IMPLEMENTING IT'S
NOT SOMEBODY OUTSIDE MANDATED
THE MATURE NEGOTIATED- AND
YOU'RE IMPLEMENTING THOSE
INCREASES IS THAT RIGHT. THAT
IS THAT IS A CORRECT WAY TO PUT
IT SIR MON WE ARE WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING A PAY INCREASES
FOR OUR UNIONIZED LABOR- I
SUPPORT IT BELIEVE ME I
SUPPORTED IT JUST THE WAY IT
WAS SAID MANDATORY IT SOUND
LIKE SOMEBODY FROM OUTSIDE. OF
OUR DID THAT BUT YOU INTERNALLY
DID NEGOTIATIONS FOR WORKERS
SALARIES AND BENEFITS ARE FOR
YOUR EMPLOYEES. THAT IS CORRECT
SIR I WON'T CALL. ANYMORE
WHILE. VERY WHAT WILL LET YOU
GO THIS HEARING. A LET ME JUST
ASK A- ONE LAST QUESTION A
FINANCE ONE OF THE THINGS IT'S
WITH REGARD TO POTENTIAL. ARE
OFFERED TUITION INCREASE IS
COHORT BASED TUITION AND AT AND
I JUST WONDERED IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS ANY
POSITION OR VIEWS ON THAT
CONCEPT. WE DON'T WILL NOTE
THAT ARE AT. OUR PROPOSED
AUGMENTATION OF A HUNDRED AND
FOUR MILLION FOR GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET COMES WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT. UNDERGRADUATE
RESIDENT TUITION AND FEES
REMAINED FLAT IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM THE UC NOTED. IN THE
FUTURE ACTIONS ARE UNKNOWN AT
THIS TIME FROM THE REGION'S
PERSPECTIVE AND SO WE ARMY
PERSPECTIVE AT THIS TIME OKAY.
WELL WE'LL KEEP CHECKING IN
COUNT ON IT. WELL OF IT AND
THEN LET ME GO TO MEMBERS OF-
SENATOR MEANT. THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES- I JUST WANT TO
FIRST- REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE
IN MY VIEW OF THE DAYS FUNDING
INCREASES- THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT AS I SUGGESTED
EARLIER AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THIS- MY PERSONAL QUESTIONS
ARE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND
THE FIRST ONE JUST ECHOES- OF
THE TESTIMONY FROM UC'S
WITNESS. AROUND THE CONDITION
REQUIRING THAT THERE BE AN
INCREASE IN OF 10% AND ONLINE
OFFERINGS. AS YOU MAY KNOW
BEFORE JOINING THE STATE SENATE
I WAS A FACULTY MEMBER AT UC
IRVINE AND I MYSELF TALK ONLINE
CLASSES DURING THE SPRING AND
FALL SEMESTERS IN TWENTY TWENTY
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. AND I HAVE
A LOT OF CONCERNS I CAN TELL
YOU FROM FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE
THAT ONLINE TEACHING IS
GENERALLY A POOR SUBSTITUTE FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION- BUT
THERE'S ALSO A NUMBER OF OTHER
PRINCIPLES I THINK IMPORTANT
HERE FIRST- THERE'S THIS
CONCEPT OF ACADEMIC FREEDOM
WHICH IS A REALLY A CORE
PRINCIPLE OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
R. THE IDEA IS THAT PROFESSORS
SHOULD BE IN THE BEST POSITION
TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS
REGARDING PEDAGOGY KEEPING
TEACHING METHODOLOGIES AND
LIKEWISE. AND I BELIEVE THAT A
REQUIREMENT 410% ACROSS THE
BOARD INCREASE IN ONLINE
LEARNING WOULD ALMOST CERTAINLY
INFRINGE ON THE PEDAGOGICAL
AUTONOMY OF. PROFESSORS AND
OTHER FACULTY. I SECOND. EVEN
IF IT WAS A PRO TO. ON ACADEMIC
FREEDOM. I WOULD THINK THAT
THIS DECISION TO PUT MORE
ONLINE EDUCATION WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATELY MADE BY
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS.
POSSIBLY BY CAMPUSES. IF IT WAS
SEEM NECESSARY TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF STATEWIDE PUSH. OUT
FROM THE REGION'S RATHER THAN
FROM SACRAMENTO- PARTICULARLY
GIVEN THAT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THERE IS JUST A- PLETHORA
RESEARCH SUGGESTING. THAT IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION IS MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN ONLINE LEARNING
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE IS
TRUE MYSELF. I ALSO THINK
EQUITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT HERE
BECAUSE- YEAH I BELIEVE THE
RESEARCH SHOWS AND THIS IS
CERTAINLY MY EXPERIENCE WITH
ONLINE TEACHING. THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION ALLOWS YOU TO
CREATE MORE EQUITABLE OUTCOMES
IN ONLINE LEARNING WHICH HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BAD IMPACTS
ON LOW INCOME. NONTRADITIONAL
AND FIRST TIME STUDENTS WHO ARE
ALREADY YOU KNOW HAVING A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES THEY'RE
FACING. SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
YOU ISSUES ONE OF THE POLICY
RATIONALES. FOR THIS
REQUIREMENT AND CAN YOU OUTLINE
FOR US THE EVIDENCE AND DATA
SUPPORTING. THE IDEA THAT THIS
10% INCREASE IN ONLINE.
EDUCATION WOULD SUPPORT YOUR
POLICY. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS SENATOR MANDATE. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE IS
FIRST THE PROPOSAL IS A BERMAN
EQUITY IN ACCESS LANDS FOCUSED
FIRST ON THE STUDENTS WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE. OUR RANGE OF
OPINIONS AND CHALLENGES THAT
FACULTY AND EVERYONE HAVE FACED
IN A SPECIALLY IN THE CODE
ENVIRONMENT- THOSE ARE WIDELY
REPORTED IN THE NEWS. BUT THE
POLICY RATIONALE IS FIRST IF
YOU THINK ABOUT STUDENTS FIRST
AND YOU GO STATEWIDE NOT JUST
IN THE UC SYSTEM BUT THE CCC'S
THE CSU'S. THERE'S A WIDE RANGE
OF GEOGRAPHICAL AND FINANCIAL
PRESSURES. THAT THAT ESPECIALLY
NONTRADITIONAL ON UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS FACE. SO
THE GOAL IS TAKE TO CREATE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND FREEDOM FROM A
STUDENT'S PERSPECTIVE SO IF YOU
HAVE TWELVE UNITS NOW SAY. AND
AN ONLINE COURSE WOULD ALLOW
YOU TO MAYBE TAKE THAT THAT ONE
MORE COURSE FOR FIFTEEN UNITS
DURING A SEMESTER FOR EXAMPLE
THAT'S GOING TO BE DRAMATICALLY
HELP MORE HELPFUL IN HELPING
YOU MOVE THROUGH FOR THE
DEGREE. I CUT YOUR COSTS OVER
TIME OF HOW MUCH IT YOU KNOW IT
COST YOU TO GET THAT DEGREE AND
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE NOW HAVE.
THERE WAIT ON STUDENTS BEFORE
COVERED THE COATED COVERED HAS
NOW MADE WORSE. AND SO WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING NOT JUST WITH
YOU SEE BUT WITH THE ALL THE
SEGMENTS. IS THAT NOW THAT
WE'VE PROVEN AS INSTITUTIONS WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HAVE. OUR
ONLINE COURSES BROADLY. WE
SHOULD PRESERVE SOME OF THAT SO
THAT GOING FORWARD ESPECIALLY
THE NONTRADITIONAL AND
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS WHO
FACE. DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS
OF THESE THESE PRESSURES ON
THEIR FLEXIBILITY. THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS NOT JUST TO YOU SEE
WHAT AT THE CSU IN CCC'S.
ONLINE OFFERINGS. IT SO THAT IN
THESE CASES THEY CAN THEY CAN
TAKE MORE UNITS OR HAVE ACCESS
AND GET THROUGH. SO TO THE TO
THE POINT ABOUT THE QUALITY I
DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC DATA ON
HAND BUT THE CCC'S WHO HAVE
TRADITIONALLY SERVED. THE MOST
NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN THE
BIGGEST PROPORTION ONLINE. THEY
HAVE DONE RESEARCH AND NOTED
THAT. ABOUT A DECADE AGO THE-
THE STUDENT PERFORMANCE THIS
THE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES WERE
WORKING THERE'S A GAP BETWEEN
IN PERSON AND ONLINE THAT GAP
IS SUBSTANTIALLY CLOSE TO
ALMOST. OUR EQUALS SUCCESS IN
ONLINE COURSES AND NOW THAT
THEY'VE HAD A DECADE OF REALLY
FOCUSING ON DEVELOPING IT AND
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'VE KEPT IN MIND WHEN TRYING
TO EMPHASIZE THAT. ONLINE
SHOULD BE PART OF THE MIX GOING
FORWARD SO CUT THAT I'LL CUT IT
OFF RIGHT THERE BUT I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS AND- I
MEAN IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T I
JUST I GUESS I DIDN'T HEAR ANY
EVIDENCE TO MY AND I THE
CONCERN I HAVE RUN EQUITY WHICH
IS. YOU KNOW MY BELIEF AND
CERTAINLY A NUMBER OF OTHER
FACULTY THAT I'VE TALKED WITH
SHARE THIS VIEW THAT- ONLINE
LEARNING IS BAD BUT IT'S
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC FOR A
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS. WHO
FACE MANY MORE CHALLENGES AND
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY VERY VERY
PROBLEMATIC FROM EQUITY PRIME
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE IT TENDS.
THE PERFORMANCES MAY DECLINE A
LITTLE BIT FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ARE HIGH PERFORMING YOU KNOW
TENTH GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS- BUT THE GAPS ARE MUCH
WIDER WITH THOSE WHO ARE FIRST
TIME COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO ARE
LOW INCOME OR NONTRADITIONAL.
AND I GUESS I I'M SERIOUS IF
THAT THOUGHT HAS CROSSED THE
MINDS. OF THE FOLKS CRAFTING
THE POLICY. YEAH I'LL UNDER THE
CONCERN AND NOTE THE AS A
MENTIONED THIS. WHICH WERE.
FAMILIAR WITH THE DEEPEST DIVE
IN THE EVIDENCE. AGAIN I DON'T
HAVE THE SPECIFIC NUMBERS BUT
THEY HAVE SHOWED THAT OVER THE
LAST DECADE OR SO. WHEN THEY
REALLY FOCUS ON ONLINE
EDUCATION THAT GAP BETWEEN
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE IN ONLINE
VERSUS IN PERSON. HAS
DRAMATICALLY NARROWED. THAT WAS
ALSO TRUE OF UNDER REPRESENTED
AND MINORITY STUDENTS- I THINK
AS YOU HAVE YOU KNOW AS YOU
MENTIONED THERE THERE ARE THERE
GAPS EXIST BUT THE PROGRESS HAS
BEEN. DRAMATIC AND SUBSTANTIAL
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
SPECIFICALLY THE CCC'S WERE
ONLINE I WAS A LARGER
PROPORTION OF COURSES AND SO
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THAT HAS
HELPED INFORM. JUST UP FROM IF
THAT'S HELPFUL I APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPONSE I DON'T KNOW IF
THE UC REPRESENTATIVE HAS ANY
RESPONSE TO THAT. THANK YOU
CENTER MAN- WE WOULD PREFER ARE
LIKE I SAID AT THIS TIME DID
NOT HAVE A SPECIFIC PERCENTAGE
INCREASE. LINK TO OUR ONLINE
COURSES AND WE DO SEE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A POTENTIAL
EXPANSION ESPECIALLY IN THE
SUMMER AND- IN OFFERING
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO DO
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE OF THE
TRADITIONAL UNIVERSITY
STUDYING. BUT TAKE ONLINE
COURSES BUT WE WOULD PREFER TO
FULLY STUDY WHAT HAPPENED
DURING A REMOTE INSTRUCTION.
AND THE SUCCESS THE DIFFERENT
STUDENT GROUPS HAD- DURING THAT
TIME THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THANK YOU- YEAH I GUESS I GUESS
I I'M REMAIN TO BE CONVINCED
BUT- I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE- THE PARMA FINEST. A
SECOND CONCERN IT ONE OF YOUR
OTHER CONDITIONS WITH THE DUAL
MISSIONS PATHWAY. I WANT TO
ECHO SOME OF THE L. A. O.
OFFICES CONCERNS. AND I GUESS I
FIRST HAD A QUESTION I WASN'T
CLEAR FROM READING OUR- OUR
BRIEFING. WHAT YOU STUDENT
BEING IN SO SAY YOU'RE SCARED
IN MY- I WANTED. TO FORMED- TO
CUSTOMER COLLEGE AND ALSO THE
UC IRVINE AND LET'S JUST SAY
THAT STUDENT GOT A PERFECT GPA
COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGES OVER
TWO YEARS- GOT INTO USC AND UC
BERKELEY. WOULD THEY BE LOCKED
INTO ATTENDING UCI OR COULD BE
ATTEND ANOTHER COLLEGE AT THAT
POINT. I GUESS THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR-
WE DO NOT ENVISION THE DUAL
ADMISSIONS PROPOSAL TO BLOCK A
STUDENT IN PERFECT BY ITS
SUPPLY OPTION FOR THEM TO HAVE
GUARANTEED ADMISSION UP FRONT
TO A SPECIFIC CAMPUS. BUT OF
COURSE IF THAT STUDENT ALSO
APPLIED TO OTHER UNIVERSITIES
AND WORK TO ACCEPT AN OFFER FOR
TRANSFER OR IF THEY WERE TO
APPLY FOR FRESHMAN ADMISSION
WELL AND ACCEPTED ONE OF THOSE
OFFERS THEY WOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE TO THEM
AS WELL. GOT IT SO THE STUDENT
IS NOT LOCKED IN THE STUDENT IF
THEY PERFORM WELL CAN GO
WHEREVER THEY WANT ON THE OTHER
HAND. IF THE STUDENT DECIDES TO
THE STATE UC IRVINE OR IF THEY
PERFORM MAYBE NOT AS WELL AS
THEY MIGHT UC IRVINE IS LOCKED
INTO THE STUDENT SO LONG AS A
STUDENT MEANS THE BASIC MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING. A TWO
POINT FOUR GPA IS THAT CORRECT.
THE DOOR ADMISSION. PROPOSAL AS
AS WRITTEN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE. THE FINANCIALLY WE
SEE THAT A NEW. OPTION AN
ADDITIONAL. FOR STUDENTS THAT
WOULD OFFER THEM SOME GUARANTEE.
UP FRONT BEFORE THEY EVEN
STARTED THEIR COLLEGE
COURSEWORK. BUT THEY WOULD
STILL HAVE OTHER PATHWAYS
AVAILABLE TO THEM. BUT THEY
COULD STILL PURSUE A DIFFERENT
PATH IF THEY SO CHOOSE THEY
WOULD JUST HAVE A LOCKED AND-
YOU'LL EMISSIONS AGREEMENT FOR.
A SPECIFIC UC CAMPUS OFFERING.
GUARANTEED ADMISSION ASSUMING
THEY COMPLETE. THE REQUIREMENTS
ARE OUTLINED AND NOT AGREEMENT
SO THERE MAY BE SPECIFIC. GPA
REQUIREMENT- COURSEWORK
REQUIREMENTS FOR THEIR TIME AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND
OTHER AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
WITHIN THAT THEY HAVE TO
COMPLETE FRIENDS AND- THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSEWORK
WITHIN TWO ACADEMIC YEARS IN
ORDER FOR THE TOILET MISSION TO
GREEN TO BE VALID. THE FONG AT
THE STUDENT FOLLOWS THAT.
AGREEMENT THE TERMS OF THE
AGREEMENT. THEY WOULD HAVE A
GUARANTEED ADMISSION FOUGHT FOR
TRANSFER. UC CAMPUS. HOWEVER
THEY CAN STILL OPTIONS TO
ATTEND A DIFFERENT CAMPUS IF
THEY- DECIDE TO APPLY THROUGH A
DIFFERENT ROUTE OR TO GO TO AN
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTION
CURRENT. SO IT'S A ONE WAY
OPTION BASICALLY LOCKS IN THE
UC. BUT NOT THE STUDENTS. RIGHT
YEAH. I MY ONLY MY FOR IS IT
SHOULDN'T THESE TO YOU OF PER
MATT I MEAN THEY THEY MATTERS.
FOR THE SUIT THE STUDENT CAN WE
ON TO. A QUOTE UNQUOTE BAY OR
DIFFERENT INSTEAD IF THEY WANT.
AND I GUESS YOU KNOW NOT A LIKE
YOU KNOW I'VE FROM THE CHICAGO
SO HERE. I MEAN IT SEEMS TO ME
LIKE THIS PROPOSAL IS FRAUGHT
WITH WHAT ECONOMISTS CALL MORAL
HAZARD RIGHT. WHICH IS THAT IF
I KNOW THAT I'M GOING TO GET
INTO THE SCHOOL NO MATTER WHAT
AS LONG AS I GET A TWO POINT
FOUR GPA. I DON'T HAVE A LOT O
INCENTIVES TO NECESSARILY WATER
pTHE STATUS QUO RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF GREAT STUDENTS
WHO TO. APPLY THEMSELVES TO TWO
YEARS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE THEY
THEN APPLY TO YOU SEASON CSU'S
THEY GET IN SOMEWHERE
PRESUMABLY- THEY GET ACCEPTED
THEY DECIDE TO GO. I MEAN THIS
SEEMS LIKE IT'S JUST KIND OF
CREATING- IT AGAIN AS I SAID A
MORAL HAZARD PROBLEM. WHERE I
KNOW I'VE GOT A SAFETY NET
HERE- IN MY GOING TO
PERFORMANCE I GUESS MY. REAL
CONCERN IS DOES THIS SET UP. DO
YOU SYSTEM MANY. WITH A REAL
RECIPE FOR FAILURE HERE I MEAN
YOU KNOW IT'S ALREADY HARD FOR
A LOT OF THE STUDENTS YOU'RE
YOU'RE TARGETING- LOCAL
STUDENTS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED IN UC'S AND NOW YOU'RE
SAYING TO THEM YOU JUST NEED TO
GET TWO POINT FOUR GPA AND YOU
GET TO GO TO THE YOU SEE THAT
YOU WERE ADMITTED TO. ME THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY SEEM LIKE
IT'S SETTING STUDENTS UP FOR
SUCCESS RIGHT RATHER THAN
TAKING THE SORT OF CREAM OF THE
CROP UP FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS IS THE CASE NOW
THOSE STUDENTS THAT SEEM MOST
LIKELY TO PERFORM AT A HIGH
LEVEL AND I GUESS MY REAL
QUESTION IS SHOULDN'T THESE TWO
YEARS OF PERFORMANCE AS
DEMONSTRATED IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MATTER IN ADMISSIONS
DECISIONS. ABSOLUTELY THE TWO
YEARS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
PERFORMANCE. SHOULD AND WOULD
MATTER. FOR TRANSFER ADMISSION-
I WOULD NOTE WITH REFERRED TO A
SPECIFIC GPA REQUIREMENT. THE
DOOR MISSION PROPOSAL DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY TIE ITSELF TO A
CERTAIN GPA REQUIREMENTS. IN
FACT BECAUSE WE ENVISION AS
BEING OFFERED AT ANY UC CAMPUS.
WE HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED AND PUT
LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT. IF THE STUDENT
HAS SELECTED A MAJOR OR A
CAMPUS THAT IS IMPACTED. BUT
YOU CAN USE THE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ESTABLISH SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL CRITERIA. FOR
INTENT THAT MAY BE A HIGHER GPA
REQUIREMENT IF A STUDENT HAS
CHOSEN- AND IMPACTED CAMPUS OR
A PROGRAM THAT'S MORE
COMPETITIVE. SO IN SOME CASES
YOU SEE WOULD HAVE. AT LARGE IN
EVERY CASE YOU SEE WOULD HAVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE
THE SPECIFIC TO A MISSION
CRITERIA WE'VE JUST REQUIRED TO
PASS THE OUTLINED UP FRONT.
YOU'RE CONFIRMING THAT THAT
MIGHT HAVE EQUITY IMPLICATIONS.
ARE QUALITY AT THE END- ALLUDED
SHE WAS ACTUALLY TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO BE PRODUCTIVE
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS. FROM
MEDICAID FOR MEDITATION. IN
VARIOUS WAYS. THANK YEAH WHAT
IT HIGH CURRICULUM OF A- OR
FINANCE ISSUES. I WILL JUST
THAT THE NEW OF INCREASE FROM.
ON THE TO THE HOUSE OF THE AND-
WE'RE CERTAINLY. NOT NOT AND
THAT THAT'S WHY RESULT IN.
LOWERED TO FOR OF THE COMMUNITY.
WERE BEING ADDED ACTUALLY
STRONG A STRONG BENEFIT TO
THOSE STUDENTS WHO FOR INSTANCE
MAY BE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT. RIGHT UP FRONT OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL THEY COULD RECEIVE
NOT ONLY GUARANTEE OF ADMISSION
BUT A VERY CLEAR PLAN THAT
SAYS. THESE ARE THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT I NEED TO
MAKE WHICH CAN HELP THEM
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE JOURNEY NOT NECESSARILY
AS THIS WITH THE BARE MINIMUM I
WANT YOU ANY BETTER THAN THAT.
BUT JUST SO THAT THEY HAVE IT
SPELLED OUT BECAUSE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HEARD WITH THE
TRANSFER PROCESS. IS THAT
SOMETIMES STUDENTS FIND IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE SO THAT'S
WHAT CREATE AN UP FRONT. MORE
CLEARLY DEFINED OPTION FOR THEM
WHERE THEY WOULD KNOW WHAT KIND
OF THEIR MINIMUM EXPECTATION
IS. BUT OF COURSE. YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO LIMIT ON THAT THAT
THEY NEED TO PERFORM ONLY TO
THAT MINIMUM. AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE. OF GOING ABOVE AND
BEYOND. I GUESS I GUESS MY
QUESTION AND I JUST BE
INTERESTED ONE MORE ABOUT THIS
AN AWFUL CERTAINLY- LOOK FORTY
HEARING MORE ABOUT THIS.
PROGRAM BUT- IT WOULDN'T BE
MORE DIRECT IF THE GOALS ARE
EQUITY IS FINDING LOCAL
STUDENTS- PROVIDING MORE
CLARITY. WOULDN'T IT BE EASIER
TO JUST TACK ON AS DALY-
SUGGESTS TO THE EXISTING
PATHWAYS. AND JUST TO SAY LIKE
HEY YOU SEE I NEED TO TAKE A
CERTAIN NUMBER. OF LOCAL
STUDENTS FOR FIRST TIME
STUDENTS WHO ARE- PERHAPS OF A
CERTAIN MINORITY POPULATION- OR
IN ANY OTHER FACTORS THAT WE
WANT WOULDN'T THAT BE EASIER.
AND AVOID SOME OF THAT MAYBE
MORAL HAZARD IN IN SORT OF
OTHER PROBLEMS THAT MIGHT. BE A
CORD WITH THE APPROACH
SUGGESTED NOW. WE JUST SAID
OKAY YOU HAVE TO TAKE A NUMBER
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF COLLEGE
TRANSFERS- YOU KNOW THAT THAT
SEEMS LIKE THAT MIGHT BE MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD RIGHT.
ENGINEERS BECAUSE THAT YOU GUYS
ONE. THERE ARE EXISTING FIREMEN
FONG YOU SEE IN TERMS OF-
TRANSFORMATION- TRANSFER
FRESHMAN RATIO WHICH THEY HAVE
BEEN ADHERING TO- WE WOULD NOTE
THERE ARE SOME SOME. BUT THERE
IS SOME COMPLEXITY IN TERMS OF
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION I'M
LIMITATION ON THE UNIVERSITY OF
BEING ABLE TO TAKE SPECIFIC
QUOTAS THAT. FOR INSTANCE UNDER
REPRESENTED OR CERTAIN MINORITY
GROUPS STUDENT. ANSWER FOR
HAVING SORT OF AN EXPLICIT
REQUIREMENT ON THAT IN SOME
CASES WOULD NOT BE PERMISSIBLE.
FIVE SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING THAT
THIS PROPOSAL APARTMENT
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS THAT IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO EXISTING
TRANSFER PATHWAYS IN THE PLAN
BUT IT IS TIED TO THE STUDENT
COMPLETION OF AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER. OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR IF YOU SEE
EQUIVALENT IF YOU SEE OFFICE TO
ESTABLISH OR USE AN EXISTING
PROGRAMS IN A QUICK WENT TO AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
OR ANOTHER ESTABLISHED TRANSFER
PATHWAY. THAT STUDENTS WOULD
HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TRANSCRIPTOMIC OF THE EXISTING
TRANSFER PATHWAYS. BUT THE
DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE THE OPTION OF HAVING
A GUARANTEE OF ADMISSION FOR
ANY CAMPUS UP FRONT BEFORE
THEY'VE EVEN STARTED THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSE
WORKING THAT HAVE THAT. KNOCKED
OUT FOR THEM I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I CERTAINLY SHARE MANY OF
THE GOALS THAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING HERE. MY LAST
QUESTION- I GUESS ALSO FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE CONCERNS ABOUT RISING
TUITION AND I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR HAS
REPEATEDLY. EMPHASIZED IS
TRYING TO KEEP. TUITION FLAT.
FOR YOU CAN PERHAPS TIMES OF
THIS A- THAT YOU'RE GIVING TO
MAYBE ALONG TERM. ON HOLDING TO
STUDY. AT THE- OUR PERSPECTIVE
ON TUITION IS SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO RIGHT NOW I WOULD NOTE THAT
AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM THE UC
MENTIONED THE UC RIDGE REGIONS
DON'T HAVE A AN ACTUAL ACTION
FRONT OF THEM SO THE- OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS WE DON'T HAVE A
VIEW. GO BEYOND THAT. I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU CENTER CENTER
OF TROUBLE. JUST ONE QUESTION-
AND I THINK. NOT SURE BECAUSE
TO THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OR THE YOU SEE THAT MY
QUESTION IS THERE A FINANCIAL
BENEFIT. FOR ONLINE LEARNING-
ON AS YOU'RE PROMOTING THE
INCREASE IN TEN PERCENT- FOR
ONLINE STUDENTS IS THERE A
BENEFIT OF COST BENEFIT TO
DOING AN ONLINE SCHOOLING
PROGRAM VERSUS AN IN PERSON
PROGRAM. THIRD THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE BENEFIT FOR THE
STUDENT IS THAT. THEN IT'S
NUMBER ONE FOCUSED ON THE TIME
IT TAKES YOU TO GET A DEGREE.
IT TAKES YOU TWO YEARS TO ONCE
YOU'VE TRANSFERRED TO UC TO GET
THAT FOR YOUR BACHELORS- THAT'S
MUCH CHEAPER THAN IT TAKING YOU
TWO AND A HALF OR THREE YEARSAND WE'VE WE'VE NOTED THAT OVER
THE LAST TEN OR SO YEARS A BIG
EMPHASIS OF THE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN ON. AFFORDABILITY FOR
COLLEGE ONE OF THE- HE
STRATEGIES FOR MAKING COLLEGE
MORE AFFORDABLE. IS TO MAKE IT
SO THAT YOU CAN GET OUT. FINISH
YOUR OF YOUR YOUR INTENDED
DEGREE WITH AS FEW UNITS AS
POSSIBLE SO JUST JUST DO THE
NUMBER YOU NEED DON'T DO
MORNING UNITS BUT ALSO I. TAKE
FIFTEEN UNITS THANK MORE.
THAT'S GONNA BE MORE EFFECTIVE
IN TAKING JUST TWELVE OR JUST
SIX BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO
STRETCH OUT THE TIME IT TAKES
YOU SO IT'S NOT IN THE TUITION
ISN'T IMPACTED BUT IT'S THE
OVERALL COST. OF HOW LONG DO
YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR COLLEGE NOT
JUST IN TUITION BUT ALL THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED LIVING IN AND
FOOD AND ALL THIS THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THE I'M A GREAT
SO THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE IS.
IF WE CAN GET YOU THROUGH MORE
EFFICIENTLY WHICH ONLINE DOES
HELP- THEN THEN IT'S GONNA BE
HELP WITH AFFORDABILITY. THANK
YOU THANK AND I HAVE A HAND
FROM THE UC REPRESENTATIVE TO
DO OF THE COMMENT YOU WISH TO.
THANK YOU SIR- I JUST LIKE TO
SAY THAT FROM THE UNIVERSITY'S
PERSPECTIVE THE ONLINE COURSES
ARE ACTUALLY NOT LESS EXPENSIVE%
TO OFFER. OF TEN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
DO AN ONLINE FOR SWELLED WITH
EXCELLENT CONTENT- WELL-
CRAFTED HOMEWORK AND EXAMS FOR
THE STUDENTS. IT'S TURNING OUT
TO BE QUITE EXPENSIVE SO I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY'S PERSPECTIVE TH
COST- IS NOT AS MUCH LESS AS
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT
IT MIGHT BE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. ARE THAT WILL
COMPLETE OUR CONSIDERATION OF
ISSUE TWO. AND I THINK THAT WAS
THE BIG ONE OF BUT I KNOW THAT
WE HAVE JUST OVER AN HOUR LEFT
WE WRE SHOOTING TO BE DONE BY
ELEVEN THIRTY SO. I DON'T KNOW
ON PART OF IT TOO SO WILL TRY
IF WE CAN ALL TRY TO DISCIPLINE
OURSELVES WILL STILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE IS ANY
AT THE END OF THIS SO WE NEED
TO MOVE ALONG. SO MOVED ISSUE
NUMBER THREE UC AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES IT'S THE
SAME. THE SAME PANELISTS. SO
WE'LL START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. RIGHT DEPARTMENT
FIGHTING- THANK YOU CHAIR ALL
ALL KNOW THE BREVITY AND GOING
FORWARD WILL BE FREE FOR THE
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES AND DO YOU
SEE THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES A ONE
POINT NINE. ELLEN DOLLAR-
GENERAL FUND. AUGMENTATION
THAT'S TO SUPPORT OPERATING
COSTS OF. AMERICANS WITH
RELIABLE FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. OF THE STATE OR
TENANTS FOR YOU STATE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES IT'S A
STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
RESEARCHERS AND EDUCATORS
PROVIDING RESEARCH ND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THE
NUMBERS CONSTITUENTS STATEWIDE.
AND OUTLINES THE VERY WELL SO I
WON'T GO INTO THE INDIVIDUALS
PROGRAMS OF THE A AND R. IF YOU
WANT TO COMMENT THAT- WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
RESTORATION OF UC'S BUDGET
WHICH ALSO MAKES A AND R.
BRINGS A IN OUR SPENDING LEVELS
IN. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY LEVEL AND ALSO THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET. AND
PROVIDE A COST INCREASE OR IN
OUR- BUT I DO WANT TO SAY IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED SEPARATE
LINE ITEM FOR YOU C. O. P. WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT ALL OF YOU
C. O. P. BE ALLOWED TO GO BACK
TO WHAT'S CALLED A CAMPUS
ASSESSMENT. WHERE THE
CHANCELLOR'S ADVICE THE
PRESIDENT AND RETURNS ON THE
FUNDING LEVEL FOR YOU C. O. P.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL RATES A
PARTIAL ASSESSMENT JUST FOR A
AND R. BUT WE WOULD PREFER ALL
OF YOU SEE- PICO BACK TO. THE
CAMPUS ASSESSMENT MODEL UP. IF
THE ASSESSMENT REMAINS IN THE
BUDGET FOR ONLY AND ARE IT
WOULD BE A CONVERSATION BETWEEN
THE CHANCELLOR'S THE PRESIDENT
REGION'S ON THE APPROPRIATE
FUNDING LEVEL AND WHAT PROGRAMS
ARE PROVIDED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY. MUCH LMAO.
GRAYSON CONSUL OR OF I BRIDGES
MYSELF EDUCATION CALL. SALLY L.
SO THE ISSUES FACING HERE VERY
SIMILAR TO- YOU DISCUSSED IN
THIS ONE MUCH SPACE PROVIDE IN
THIS IT'S IT SPECIFIC DIVISION
YOU SEE RATHER THAN ON THE
CAMPUSES BUT VERY SIMILAR
ISSUES IN TERMS OF THE LEVEL
SUPPORT AND THE- GENERAL FUND
LIMITED CAPACITY FOR ONGOING
ASSAULTS- I DID WANT O TOUCH
ON TO SPECIFIC IN OUR ISSUES TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION. THE FIRST IS
THAT- A FEW WEEKS AGO AT THE IN
OUR DIVISION SUBMITTED TO OUR
OFFICE AND INDEPENDENT COST
PRESSURE ANALYSIS. ACTED GROWTH
IN ITS JOB. EMPLOYEE BENEFITS
OPERATING EXPENSES. AND I DO
THAT ANALYSIS IN OUR SPENDING
WOULD GROW TO SEVENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. AND I JUST FOR
COMPARISON- UNDER THEIR
FAVORITE GREEN IT WHICH FOCUSES
ON A RESTORATION TO- FREE CODE
LEVELS. IN OURS- FUNDING
SUPPORT WOULD BE SEVENTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION SO THERE'S A
BIT OF A GAP THERE- IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE INTERESTED IN
AND LEARNING MORE ABOUT THIS
WEEK WE THINK IT IT COULD YOU
GO MORE INTO THE SPENDING PLAN-
AS THE COMMITTEE NOTED IN THE
LAST ISSUE- YOU SEE SPENDING
ISN'T NECESSARILY MANDATORY-
THEY'RE A MIX OF. ISSUES THAT
ARE SOME OF THEM ARE MORE
DISCRETIONARY SOME OF THE MOST
DISCRETIONARY SO LEGISLATURE
COULD WEIGH THOSE ISSUES WE
ALSO FOUND THAT A WIN THAT
DIVISION WAS PROJECTING SALARY
INCREASES. HIS PROJECTIONS
WERE- EXCEEDING MOST MEASURES
OF INFLATION SO I GET. TO BE
NICE TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BETTER. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TELL ON IT. TO THE ARAB
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL AND
AGAIN I KNOW THAT JUST LIKE THE
LAST ISSUE THERE ARE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT PACKAGES AND I'M I'M
HAPPY TO ELABORATE FOR THE
COMMITTEE MORE ON THE DIFFERENT
PACKAGES. THIS IS STILL A
LITTLE HARD TO FOLLOW BY EACH-
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS WAS- A PROPOSAL TO
CREATE A NEW CAMPUS ASSESSMENT
TO SUPPORT A AND R. THE
REGIONAL INTENT OF THIS CAMPUS
IS TESTAMENT. WE'RE CAMPUSES
WHERE WOULD BE CHARGED TO
SUPPORT IN OUR DELIBERATIONS
WAS TO RESTORE IN OURS LEVELS
ON THREE MAJOR GENERAL FUND.
AND THIS NEW CAMPUS BE. NOW
WITH THE OF. GREENMAN PLAY AND
STATE PROVIDE. A REST. ENTIRELY
THE GENERAL FUND. ON THE STATUS
OF THE OF THIS PROPOSAL IS A
LITTLE UNCLEAR TO LAST. TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT STILL REMAINS ON
THE TABLE WE RECOMMEND. ARE
REJECTING- THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL WE DON'T THINK THERE'S
A CLEAR POLICY BASIS TO CHARGE
CAMPUSES ON TO SUPPORT. IN OUR-
AND ARTISANS IT'S A PROVIDE
CAMPUSES ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES INSTEAD OF SEPARATE
PROGRAM AND A LOT OF ITS
PROGRAMMING OCCURS I'M OFF
CAMPUS. WITHOUT IT WE HAVE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I HAVE ONE QUESTION
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS- OF FOR
VESTER LEGISLATORS THAT
REPRESENT MONTEREY COUNTY HAVE
A FAIRLY STRONG LETTER FROM THE
FARM BUREAU. IN WHICH OF THE
THEY BASICALLY POINT OUT TWO
THINGS THAT FUNDING HAS BEEN
FLAT IN THE- IT IN THE COUNTY
EXTENSION COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
AND THEY HAVE. EXCEPTIONAL
RESEARCH NEEDS IN RELATION TO
NOVEL PEST AND DISEASE RESEARCH
AS IT AFFECTS LEAFY GREENS WERE
THERE ARE BEEN SOME. SOME
PARTICULAR UP- ISSUES IN THAT
REGION. AND SO ES WAS JUST SAID
IT JUST SEEMS TO BE FLAT YEAR
TO YEAR AND IT SEEMS LIKE ARE
NOW ALSO THIS IS ALL IN TERMS
OF. WHAT THE MONEY IS IN THE
MONEY BEING FLAT AND WHEN IT'S
FLAT THAT MEANS IT'S A CUT
EVERY YEAR BY INFLATION AND
THEY'RE BEEN VACANCIES. ANSWER
YOUR VACANCIES AND YOU HAVE
FLAT MONEY AND YOU HAVE
EXCEEDING DEMANDS AND IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S ALL ABOUT THE MONEY.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY KIND OF
ANALYSIS OF WHETHER WE'RE
REALLY MEETING THAT DEMAND AND
THEN IT FEEDS INTO WHAT THE L.
A. O. JUST SAID. WHICH IS THIS
DEPENDS ON THE CAMPUSES ARE
PAYING IN SO THIS EXTERNAL
RESEARCH THAT IS REALLY OF
BENEFIT COMPETES AGAINST
INTERNAL CAMPUS THINGS AND ED
IN MY POLITICAL UNDERSTANDING
WOULD BE THE INTERNAL CAMPUS
THINGS WOULD ALWAYS WIN. THIS
SO HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF THE FACT THAT COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION ISN'T REALLY
ADDRESSING THE FORMALLY THAT'S
BEING IDENTIFIED BY ITS- ITS
PARTNERS RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
FOR THE CALL SIR. BACK TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE LEGISLATURE CHOSE
THE LINE ITEM TO USE OKAY
BUDGET DUE TO SOME CONCERNS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED BY THE US
STATE AUDITOR SINCE THAT TIME
THE A AND R. BUDGET HAS BEEN
HELD FLAT. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
A. N. R. RECEIVED ITS OWN LINE
ITEM- WHICH WAS FLAT AND THEN
LIKE THIS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
REDUCED DRAMATICALLY DUE TO THE
STATE BUDGET CUTS- WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE LINE ITEMS A
PARTICULAR FUNCTION WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY OF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
ALTER THAT AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
EIGHT EIGHT DIVISH STILL HAS
COST INCREASES THAT ARE- THAT.
UNIVERSITY IMPOSES OR THAT WE
CAN NEGOTIATE OF THAT GREAT BUT
ARE NOT THURMOND BUT ARE NOT
MANDATORY RIGHT. I'M JUST
KIDDING I AM. I WAS COST OF
LIVING INCREASE SAYS YOU HAVE-
NON SALARY COST INCREASES YOU
HAVE LOST INCREASES FOR UP YOUR
YOU KNOW LET ME ASK THE
QUESTION A DIFFERENT WAY
BECAUSE I THINK SOME OF THE
ACTIONS IS JUST MY SPECULATION
WERE TAKEN BY THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO SEE.
THIS PROGRAM INCREASE AND IT
MAY HAVE HAD A COUNTER
INTUITIVE- COUNTER. RESULT SO
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO GET
INCREASES IN THIS PROGRAM TO
MEET THE DEMANDS GIVEN ALL THE
THINGS THAT WERE SAYING ABOUT.
LINE ITEM NOT LINE ITEM BILLING
THAT CAMPUS IS NOT GOING TO
CAMPUSES WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO
GET AN INCREASE FOR THIS- TO
POTENTIAL ACTIONS THAT I SEE
FOR YOU SIR YOU COULD INCREASE
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT IN THE A AND
R. LINE ITEM. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN ACTIVITIES
THAT YOU WANT THEM TO UNDERTAKE
SUCH AS THE PAST MANAGEMENT-
YOU COULD THEN YOU COULD ALSO
MOVE ALL OF YOU C. O. P. OFF
THE LINE ITEM. GIVE ALL THAT
GENERAL FUND BACK TO THE
CAMPUSES AND THEN THE CAMPUS IS
COULD USE A MIX OF FUNDING
SOURCES TO FIND YOU SEE- PAGE
WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY GIVE THE
CAMPUSES MORE STATE GENERAL
FUND. FOR INSTRUCTIONAL
PURPOSES AND THEY MAY BE MORE
WILLING TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
USE YOUR PH CURRENTLY THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS ARE NOT BEING
CHARGED- THROUGH THE ASSESSMENT
WHICH WE USED TO HAVE. FOR THE
OPERATIONS OF U. C. O. P. AND
WE DO PROVIDE QUITE A BIT OF
SERVICES FOR THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM SO- IF WE WERE TO MOVE
BACK TO THE CAMPUS ASSESSMENT
BECAUSE THE CAMPUS IS WOULD USE
THE MULTITUDE OF FUNDING
SOURCES. IT COULD ACTUALLY
ALLOW US TO INCREASE THE BUDGET
FOR A AND R. I KNOW THAT WOULD
MEET YOUR CARNAL DESIRES AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE WOULD HAVE TO
DEPEND ON THE KINDNESS OF
STRANGERS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THERE WOULD ACTUALLY BE
AN INCREASE WELL WE JUST MOVED
BACK TO CAMPUS SO. I THINK I
WOULD JUST SUGGEST THAT BETWEEN
NOW AND THE MAY REVISE IT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL TO FIND A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE
WITH CERTAINTY RATHER THAN
CHANGES THE PROCESS AND THEN WE
SEE WHAT THE CAMPUSES DO. IT
BECAUSE THE REAL ISSUE IS LACK
OF RESEARCH AND A NOT FOR
RESEARCH A. M. THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER THERE NEEDS TO BE A
COST OF LIVING INCREASE WHETHER
VACANCIES NEED TO BE FILLED. ON
WHETHER THERE NEEDS TO BE A
FLAT OUT INCREASE BUT I THINK
BEFORE WE DID IT EVEN THOUGH IF
YOU'RE HEARING THERE'S A DESIRE
WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THERE'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE AN
OUTCOME- THAT THAT THE TAXI
GOING TO LEAD TO AN INCREASE IN
RATES. IF WE DID AND I'M THE
ONLY ONE THAT'S TALK ABOUT THE
STRESSFUL BUT- I JUST. THAT IF
YOU WANT TO THE MORE RURAL
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA NEAR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES OR THAT
HAVE COOPERATIVE EXTENSION DAY
WOULD FEEL STRONGLY TO SAY
MORE. SO ARE WE JUST LEAVE IT
AT THAT BUT- BUT JUST I HAVE
CLEARLY NOTED THE ISSUE AND
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A SENATOR MEANT- JUST
BRIEFLY I WANT TO ECHO MY
SUPPORTERS PROGRAM AS WELL. I
THINK IT SERVES A LOT OF
IMPORTANT PURPOSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE SO
MUCH OPEN SPACE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. WE'RE WE'RE DEALING
WITH A LOT OF- ISSUES RELATED
TO WILDLIFE- NATURAL FLORA AND
FAUNA AND WILDFIRES AND AYE AYE
AYE- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THIS PROGRAM. HE STEADILY
FUNDED. THANK YOU AND THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR
TROUBLED. APPRECIATE THAT
PANEL. WILL MOVE TO THE- THE
EXACT SAME PANEL. ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR STUDENT SUPPORTS
AND BASIC NEEDS AND WILL BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DAY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES.
FIFTEEN MILLION. ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES RESOURCES AND
ACCESS TO NECESSARY
TECHNOLOGICAL AR. OUR ONLINE
DEVICES AND HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND ACCESS FOR STUDENTS.
ALL NOTED THAT THIS IS FIFTEEN
MILLION ADDITIONAL TO AN
EXISTING FIFTEEN MILLION THAT
UC'S BUDGET ALREADY HAS OR FOOD
INSECURITY AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY WHICH ARE ARE BROADLY
SEEN AS BASIC NEEDS FOR STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES- THE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
ONE TIME FUNDING A PROPOSED
FIFTEEN MILLION. FOR EMERGENCY
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID- THAT
THAT COMES WITH SOME
SPECIFICATIONS FOR ALLOCATING
TWO CAMPUSES AND TO STUDENTS
THAT WE SPELL OUT AND BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE- THE FINAL
PROPOSAL THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAS ON THESE STUDENTS
SUPPORT SERVICES IS TO EXTEND
AN EXISTING SUMMER FINANCIAL
AID. OF FINANCING FOR PROGRAM.
FOR ONE YEAR SO CURRENTLY IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. THE
SUMMER FINANCIAL AID THE UC
RECEIVES WOULD BE CUT IN HALF
WE'RE PROPOSING TO IT WOULD BE
CUT IN HALF FROM FOUR MILLION
TO TWO MILLION BECAUSE IT
SUNSETS HALFWAY THROUGH THE
YEAR. WE'RE PROPOSING. YOU SEE
RECEIVES THE SAME FOUR MILLION
FOR SUMMER FINANCIAL AID THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO RECEIVE THIS
YEAR. AND THOSE ARE BIG
PROPOSALS WERE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT THANK YOU UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY ACCESS AS
WELL AS THE ONE TIME FINANCIAL
AID AND WE'RE REQUESTING YOUR
SUPPORT OF THESE ITEMS- I DO
WANT ALSO EXPRESSED A DEEP
APPRECIATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
EASIEST FUNDING WE HAVE
RECEIVED. WHICH HAS ALLOWED US
TO ESTABLISH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PROCESSES USED SIR STUDENTS ON
OUR CAMPUSES ONGOING FUNDING IS
CRUCIAL TO REALLY PROVIDING
BASIC NEEDS YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
REDUCING DE UM REDUCING THE
DESPERATION ON CAMPUSES FOR
SOME STUDENTS- IN TERMS OF
THESE NEW FUNDS FOR THE BASIC
NEEDS WE WOULD USE THESE FUNDS
TO. HIRE ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS ON THE
CAMPUSES TO PROVIDE TARGETED
MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSES LIKE
SCREENING TOOLS PROACTIVE
PSYCHO EDUCATIONAL WORKSHOPS
AND OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT ARE
DONE IN COLLABORATION WITH
CULTURAL AFFINITY GROUPS AND
OTHER STUDENTS SERVICES
PROGRAMS ON OUR CAMPUSES- IN
ADDITION THE STUDENT TECHNOLOGY
FUNDS COULD BE USED FOR
ACTIVITIES. SUCH AS PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH LAPTOPS AND HOT
SPOT RIGHT BY WE WOULD PROVIDE
GRANTS FOR HIGH SPEED INTERNET
ACCESS AND WE WOULD PURCHASE
LEARNING ACCESSIBILITY.
SOFTWARE FOR OUR DISABLED
STUDENTS- AT STATE REALLY LOOK
TO OUR FINANCE AID SYSTEM TO
PROVIDE AND OF HEALTH FOR
STUDENTS AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH CONGRESS TO TRY TO
INCREASE THE WHOLE GRANT AMOUNT
OR STUDENTS SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT BACK WILL ALSO IMPACT IN
THE FUTURE BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE EARLY ACTION BILL
AB EIGHTY FIVE OF THE APPROVED
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
FOR UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE CURRENT YEAR TO INCREASE
OUR CALVET BRUSH ENROLLMENTS OF
THESE FUNDS WILL ALLOW THE
CAMPUS IS TO HIRE STUDENT
WORKERS PURCHASE EQUIPMENT AND
SOFTWARE. AND UNDERTAKE OTHER.
HOW FRESH- BECAUSE WE'RE A
PUBLIC INSTITUTION AND WE HAVE
A MISSION AND REALLY STRIVE TO
SERVE LOW INCOME STUDENTS WERE
LIKELY TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
BASIC NEEDS ISSUES WELL INTO
THE FUTURE- BUT PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH THESE BASIC NEEDS
SAFETY THAT ALLOWS US TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT IT TRAINING A
COLLEGE EDUCATION POSSIBLE FOR
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME TO SPEAK TODAY.
THANK YOU LMAO. SO THIS IS ALSO
AN ISSUE THAT HAS A LOT OF
CROSSOVER TO PROPOSALS AND CSU
THE COMMITTEE DISCUSSED A LOT
OF THESE ISSUES I KNOW YOU'RE
IN TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE SO
I'LL KEEP MY COMMON SUBJECT TO
JUST A HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY OF
WHAT YOU HEARD A FEW WEEKS AGO
HAPPY ALLOWED READ MORE ON
HUMANE. FIRST BEFORE THE
PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION AN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND IN THIS
ISSUE WE KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR
IS PROPOSING TO COMBINE TWO
VERY DIFFERENT PRIORITIES
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH AND
STUDENT TECHNOLOGY AND THERE
ISN'T A CLEAR NEXUS BETWEEN
THESE TWO DIFFERENT PRIORITIES
SO IN THIS CASE WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION TO BETTER
CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF THIS-
PROPOSAL MAYBE CONSIDER.
TACKLING EACH ISSUE SEPARATELY.
FOR THE PROPOSED FFTY MILLION
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND. FOR
EMERGENCY STUDENT DATA HERE WE
KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T HAVE MUCH INFORMATION
AS- TO HOW THIS WILL AMOUNT
WOULD INTERACT WITH THE MUCH
LARGER AMOUNT OF FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDING THAT YOU SEE IS
RECEIVING ALSO FOR STUDENTS.
AND WORKING CA. I WOULD
RECOMMEND GETTING SOME MORE
INFORMATION FROM YOU SEE ON HOW
THEY INTEND TO SPEND. THEIR OF
FEDERAL RELEASE STUDENT. AID
FUNDS AND THEN DESIGNING THIS
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION AWAY
THAT- COHERENTLY INTERACTS WITH
THAT SO THAT WE'RE MAXIMIZING
THE DOLLARS AND COVERING ALL
THE INSTEAD STUDENT POPULATIONS
OF THE LEGISLATURE DESIRES- I'M
MORE. OUR OFFICE HAS NOTED SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE STATE'S
OVERARCHING APPROACH TO
SUPPORTING BASIC NEEDS AND
RECENT YEARS. ON THE STATE TO
DATE HASN'T TAKEN A VERY
UNIFIED WAY TO SUPPORT BASIC
NEEDS- DOESN'T HAVE AN
OVERARCHING PLAN TO ADDRESS
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS. AND A LOT
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED TO DATE HAVE BEEN
PIECEMEAL. WE HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS ON HOW THE STATE MIGHT
TAKE A MORE- DELIBERATE AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
TO GET HAPPY TO. ELABORATE MORE
ON THAT AND YOU MAY. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMNESTY
OTHER TWO SENATORS OF EITHER OF
THEM HAD QUESTIONS THEY WANT TO
LEAD OFF WITH ON THE SIDE. NO
ARE. WE DON'T FOR ME EITHER AND
I THINK- I WOULD JUST. MAKE A
COMMENT MAY BE IN THE INTEREST
OF- THIRD TIME BECAUSE- HE I
VISITED MY WN HOME CAMPUS RUN
THE ALMA MATER WAS THE IS MY
ALMA MATER AND WAS SURPRISED TO
FIND TO WHAT WAS REFERRED TO AS
A NON TRANSACTIONAL CAFE. AND
IT MEANT THAT OF STUDENTS COULD
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF FOOD
WITHOUT HAVING TO DEMONSTRATE
THE NEED AS TO WHY THAT IT
DIDN'T DRIVE THEM AWAY WITH THE
STIGMA THAT WAS VERY
INTERESTING TO ME THAT THAT WAS
GOING ON AND APPARENTLY THE
NEED WAS REALLY DRAMATIC AND
GIVEN BEFORE BUT PARTICULARLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. ARE EQUAL STRONG
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S-
THERE'S VACANCIES THAT STILL
EXISTED THE AT THE COUNSELING
LEVEL WHAT YOU SEE AND SO. LET
ME JUST CALL ATTENTION TO THOSE
ISSUES RATHER THAN ASK
QUESTIONS AND JUST SAY THAT WE
WILL. REALLY WANT TO WORK. BY
THE TIME THE MAY REVISE FIRMS
THINGS UP IT AND WHETHER OR
NOT. THESE ISSUES ARE IN FACT
BEING ADDRESSED BECAUSE OF THE-
BOB KARP OF REAL IMPORTANCE SO
I WOULD THANK THE PANELISTS.
AND I WOULD MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. WHICH IS- YOU SEE
PRIME GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION AND UC HEALTH
PROPOSALS IT'S THE SAME THREE
AND WILL BEGIN WITH OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO IS TO
FRAME ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS
THERE'S TWO BIG PICTURE KEY
POINTS TO KEEP IN MIND ONE IS
THERE'S A- THERE'S UNEVENNESS
ACROSS THE STATE IN TERMS OF
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. THE LAST
YEAR THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
INCLUDED NEW INVESTMENTS FOR UC
RIVERSIDE MEDICAL SCHOOL AND
ALSO UCSF UC MERCED. A
PARTNERSHIP IN FRESNO. AND THE
REASON WAS AND STILL IS THAT
THE FEDERAL RECOMMENDS SIXTY TO
EIGHTY ARE. PERSONAL PHYSICIANS
FOR EVERY HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE BUT THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY IS THAT HALF OF THAT
RECOMMENDATION SO THERE'S A
DRAMATIC NEED THERE WHEREAS
SOME OF THE URBAN AREAS TO
CALIFORNIA HOW MUCH HIGHER
RATIO PHYSICIAN TO POPULATION.
RIGHT SO TO ADDRESS THE
GEOGRAPHICAL UNEVENNESS USAGE
PRIME HAS BEEN A WITH LAST
YEAR'S INVESTMENT AND GOING
FORWARD WILL BE CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSING HEALTH RELATED
INEQUITIES. SO THE- THEY GO
BUDGET FOR TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION FOR A YOU SEE PRIME THE
PROGRAM THAT THAT SUPPORTS
MEDICAL EDUCATION IN
SPECIALIZED WAYS WITH TARGETING
SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND
GEOGRAPHICAL. AREAS THIS COMES
WITH THE SPECIFIC ACTED
SPECTATORS IN THE TWELVE POINT
NINE IS SPENT TO EXPAND
EXISTING USED IMPROPERLY GRAMS.
TO ESTABLISH A NEW NATIVE
AMERICAN FOCUSED PRIME PROGRAM.
ALSO ARE THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY OF ESTABLISHING AN
AMERICAN BUT AN ADDITIONAL
PROGRAM WHICH ARE YOU SEE HAS
INDICATED THEY WILL MAKE AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN FOCUS PROGRAM.
SO THAT WOULD BE TWO NEW PRIME
PROGRAMS. ARE AND THAT A THIRD
OF THE TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION WOULD GO TOWARDS NEEDS
BASED FINANCIAL AID FOR
STUDENTS. SO THAT'S THE PRIME
PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR ALSO HAS
TWO OTHER RELEVANT PROPOSALS
HERE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH ONE IS
AN ADDITIONAL ONE R. ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. FOR PROP
FIFTY SIX GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION- I'M BEING TOLD THAT
I SAID FOR THE UC PRIME THAT
THE- APOLOGIES FOR MISS
SPEAKING BUT THAT OUR OUR
SPECIFIC REQUEST WAS THAT THE
TWELVE POINT NINE FIND A NEW
NATIVE AMERICAN AND- PRIME
PROGRAM AND IN ADDITION TO THAT.
THE WE SPECIFIED A NEW NATIVE
AMERICAN PROGRAM WULD COME
WITH THE FUNDS. WE LEFT OPEN A
SECOND PROGRAM. WOULD BE OPEN
ENDED AND THE UC HAS AS IN IT
WILL MAKE THAT SECOND NEW UC
PRIME PROGRAM IN AFRICAN
AMERICAN. ENTERED ONE SO I MAY
HAVE MISSPOKEN THERE'S A NATIVE
AMERICAN AND AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN PROGRAMS THAT WE
EXPECT TO COME OUT OF THE
TWELVE POINT NINE. NEW PRIME
FUND. TO MOVE ON TO THE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION PROP
FIFTY SIX PROPOSAL. SO PROPERTY
SIX PROVIDED FORTY MILLION IN
AN ONGOING SPECIAL FUNDS FOR
YOU SEE BUT BECAUSE TOBACCO AS
A REVENUE SOURCE IS DECLINING
THE- THE MINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS TO BACK FILL. THAT AMOUNT
AND KEEP YOU SEE HOLE AT A
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR AMOUNT. SO
THIS YEAR WE'RE PROPOSING THAT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE UC
RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. SO THAT
THEY CAN MAINTAIN THAT FORTY
MILLION LEVEL. FIFTY SIX FUNDS.
THOSE FUNDS GO TO FIND A
RESIDENCY SLOTS FOR GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION. THE THIRD
RELEVANT PROPOSAL HERE IS WE'RE
WE'RE PROPOSING A ONE TIME ONE
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR A UC CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSORTIUM. THE CONSORTIUM WAS
BORN OUT OF THE COALBED CRISIS
IN MARCH APRIL WHERE THE STATE
NEEDED AWAY BETWEEN THE UC'S
AND WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO COORDINATE
MODELING VARIOUS SCENARIOS
RELATED TO OUR THINKING THROUGH
THE CRISIS. ARE THE NEEDED DATA
SHARING AGREEMENTS NAY NEEDED I
T. AND STAFFING SUPPORT TO DO
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH A ONE TIME WAY OF TO SET
UP A- CONSORTIUM FOR IMPROVING.
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY IN
RESPONSE TIMES. BUT IT'S
UNSUSTAINABLE IN THE WAY THAT
THEY'VE MODELED IT FINANCIALLY
NOW AND THIS ONE TIME
INVESTMENT WOULD REALLY HELP
CONTINUING THROUGH BUDGET YEAR
AND ARE AND HELP THEM FIGURE
OUT WAYS OF GOING FORWARD. TO
MAKE A CONTRIBUTION TO THE
STATE REPUBLICAN THAT CONCLUDES
OUR PRESENTATION WERE HEALTHY
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- YOU SEE. AIR
CANADA FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BUDGET
PROPOSES TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION FOR NEW INVESTMENTS IN
MEDICAL EDUCATION THAT WILL
HELP OUR STUDENTS AND THE STATE
YOU SEE PROGRAMS A MEDICAL
EDUCATION ALSO KNOWN AS PRIME
TRANSMETA CALL STUDENTS TO
PRACTICE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THOUGHT HEALTH
EQUITY IS A CENTRAL ELEMENT IN
ALL PRIME PROGRAMS THE SPECIAL
TRAINING THESE GRADUATES
RECEIVE PREPARES THEM FOR
LEADERSHIP ROLES COMMUNITY
ENGAGE CLINICIANS EDUCATORS
RESEARCHERS AND SOCIAL POLICY
ADVOCATES FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. OF SEVEN MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA LIVE IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND THE
MAJORITY OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN LAST NEXT AN
AMERICAN INDIAN- ALSO WITH IN
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE
A DOCTOR SHORTAGE ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF OUR DOCTORS ARE OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY AND THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO START
RETIRING SOON AND WE NEED TO
TRAIN TO REPLACEMENT WORK FOR
STUFF. WILL COME BEHIND THEM.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOUR
MINISTER ABOUT- HAS. FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY POINT STUDENTS-
THE FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE
GOVERNOR BOB WOULD ALLOW YOU
SEE TRUCKS BAND THE PRIME WITH
TWO NEW PROGRAMS. I WANT TO
SERVE THE AMERICAN INDIAN
NATIVE ALASKAN COMMUNITIES AND
THE OTHER TO START BY
COMMUNITIES- ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
THE FUNDING PROPOSED WOULD GO
TOWARD FINANCIAL AID FOR PRIME
STUDENTS. CURRENTLY 74% OF
PRIME STUDENTS TAKE ON STUDENT
DEBT WHILE THEY'RE ENROLLED AT
UC MEDICAL SCHOOL AND THE
AVERAGE DEBT UPON GRADUATION
FOR YOU SEE MEDICAL STUDENTS.
IS ABOUT HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THEIR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT- AND IT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO WORK IN
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE THAT KIND
OF STUDENT THAT THE FINANCIAL
AID WOULD REALLY HELP ALLEVIATE.
THAT I WANT TO KNOW- THAT WE
WERE BE PRO THE- WITH WORKING
REST. TO SOME OF THE ISSUES OF
BY THE L. A. L. I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION RIGHT THIS
MOMENT FOR WILL BE DOCTORS COM
WEEK HOPEFULLY THE WHOLE CALL.
SOME OF THE CRIME. RAISED IN
YOUR- AND I JUST TO CLOSE WITH
THAT IT TAKES- ABOUT SEVEN.
MINIMUM THE TRAIN A DOCTOR FOR
YOUR OF MEDICAL SCHOOL THREE
ABROAD. OR WHAT ALL THESE.
RETIRE VERY AND ARKHAM. IN
CRISIS WE CAN WAIT ANY LONGER
STAR TRAINING YOUR DOCTORS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
LMAO. ALL MY CAR ON CRIME
PROPOSAL AS IT'S FAR THE
LARGEST IN THIS ISSUE. FOR I
DID INTO OUR COMMENTS I FIRST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE THINK
OBJECT THAT THE ADMIN. AND THE
UNIVERSITY- I DON'T. IN THEIR
CUSTOMER. THINGS LIKE ADDRESS
LONG PHYSICIAN WERE IS.
ADDRESSING HEALTH ISSUES ARE
COMMENDED PRIOR AND WE'RE OF
COULD. IN THE STATE BUDGET.
DESPITE THE COMMENDABLE. WE
HAVE SEVERAL KINDS WITH THIS
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL. AND WE JUST
FOR ALL OVER ALL OVER ARE ON
PAGE THREE ONE OF YOUR CHEN-
BUT THAT SOMEONE OUR NUMEROUS
CAR I THOUGHT IT'D BE HELP TO-
GROUP THEM INTO THREE BUCKETS.
THE FIRST BUCKET AMERICAN. ARE
IS AROUND THE. A LACK OF LONG
TERM PLAN THAT WE IT'S- TO SOME
OF THE OBJECTS THAT ADVENTURE.
AND UNIVERSITY AYE DADDY. JUST
TO GIVE YOU ONE AND- IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE EIGHT OF YOUR
ENGINE AT YOUR SEE IN BOTH. THE
SUMMER OF THESE CRIME PRO. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU'LL IS A
THE PRIMARY HAVE MANY. MISSIONS
AVERAGE FOCUS ON HEALTHCARE.
OTHERS ARE TARGET TOWARDS ISSUE
LIKE OUR FOCUS ON THE SAME
JOAQUIN. FOCUSING ON ON THE
CERTAIN LINE AND GRAPHIC. GROUP
ARE BUT THEY KNOW SEEM
ACCORDINGLY AND BE OF THAT A DE-
YOU KNOW REMAINING OR IN USE-
EIGHT. PROGRAMMING ADDITIONAL
CAL REGION ARE CAN YOU. ARE
BEING LEFT A DRAFT. YOU SEE
ALSO LACKS A LONG TERM- PLANETS
OVER BETTER. SCHOOL IN THE- YOU
THOUGH THAT'S NOT MY PERCENT
ITS MEDIC SCHOOL. AND SO IT'S
HARD TO KNOW HOW IT'S PLANS.
HEALTH PLAN TO ADDRESS THE
PROJECT SHORTAGES IN PRIMARY
CARE BECAUSE THAT SEE- A LITTLE
TOO EARLIER. OUR SECOND. BOB OF
CONCERNS ARMS THE BUDGET. THAT
THE IS PER TO TAKE AND YOU AS.
EXAMPLE OF THE IMAGE IS PER TO
PROVIDE ALL. THE FUNDING FOR
PRIME UP FOR IN THE BY YEAR.
EVEN THOUGH MUCH OF THE WATER
OR THE NEXT. PAGE NOT ONLY DO
WE THINK PROVIDING UP FRONT UP
FRONT UP FRONT FUNDING IS
INEFFICIENT IN THAT IT PROVIDES
FUNDS AND SOME YEARS WERE LIKE
HOT WEATHER COSTS HAVE BEEN
INCURRED YET ON BUT ALSO
WEAENS LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OVER THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE FUNDS. AND HERE WE THINK
THE STATE'S EXPERIENCE OF SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY PRIME- PROVIDES
AND ARE USEFUL EXAMPLE ON IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE
STATE PROVIDED SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PRIME- FUNDS UP FRONT
FOR FORTY EIGHT STUDENTS ON
WHAT THE PROGRAM IS HAD SOME
IMPLEMENTATION DELAYS AND
CURRENTLY ENROLLS THIRTY SIX
STUDENTS- IT DOESN'T ANTICIPATE
HITTING THAT FORTY EIGHT
STUDENTS ARE MARKING TOLD. A
UNTIL A FEW YEARS FROM NOW.
REGIONALLY THE LAW. TO WHITE TO
HAVE IT. ON ON THE EMPLOYMENT
CHALLENGES BY PROVIDING THE
FUNDS ALL FRENCH MISSING
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
REVIEW THESE PLANS ANNUALLY AS
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS.
YEAH THAT'S WE JUST ONE ISSUE
WE HAVE THE BUDGET APPROACH WE
HAVE SEVERAL OTHER CONCERNS
WITHOUT. PER STUDENT FUNDING
RATE THAT YOU SEE IS PROPOSING
OF THE LACK OF ENROLLMENT
TARGETS IN THE IN THE- PROPOSED
BUDGET BILL AND ALSO THE LACK
OF REGULAR REPORTING ON TO
ASSESS THE OUTCOMES OF THE
PROGRAM AND TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS- OPERATING
EFFECTIVELY. SH THE FINAL
BUDGET OF OUR CONCERNS ARE
AROUND THE FACT IS THAT A
SIZABLE PORTION OF THESE FUNDS
ARE INTENDED ARE INTENDED TO
BOLSTER SUPPORT FOR EXISTING
ENROLLMENT DATA EXISTING
PROGRAMS. RATHER THAN FINDING
NEW ENROLLMENT GROWTH. THIS IS
A MIXED THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME JUSTIFICATION FOR EXAMPLE
THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE
UNIVERSITY NOTE THAT SOME OF
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE TO-
BOLSTER FINANCIAL AID FOR
STUDENTS AND ADDRESS THEIR
STUDENT DEBT LEVELS. WE THINK
THIS IS PROTECT POTENTIALLY
REASONABLE BUT THE UNIVERSITY
HASN'T PROVIDED A FULL ESTIMATE
OF STUDENTS NEED. ON THE
BECAUSE OF THAT THE LEGISLATURE
LITTLE BASIS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE PROPOSED ONE THIRD
SATISFIED IS THE CORRECT AMOUNT
TO. ADDRESS STUDENT DEBT LEVELS.
FURTHERMORE I SIDLE PORTION OF
THIS. WOULDN'T BE FOR FINANCIAL
DATED BEFORE OTHER RESTORATION
AND HERE WE THINK THE
UNIVERSITY HAS NOT PROVIDED
ENOUGH JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS
WEEK WE THINK THIS COULD BE
AMONG THE LEGISLATURE'S. LOWER
PRIORITIES IN THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. ALTHOUGH THAT IN
MIND- WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TAKE SEVERAL STOPS- HELP
ADDRESS THAT ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. ONE IS TO DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND YOU SEE TO
ESTIMATE. OF BETTER PROPOSALS
THE LEGISLATURE. BETTER
PROPOSAL HAVE LONG PLANNING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS I
DESCRIBED EARLIER WOULD HAVE A
BETTER PER STUDENT FUNDING RATE
FOR EXAMPLE. AND WHAT THESE
BETTER PLANS IN PLACE WITHIN
THE LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE ITS
OWN APPROACH TO SUPPORTING
PRIME ONE THAT- INSURERS IT HAS
A PROPER OVERSIGHT OVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. PROPOSAL FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE- SPREAD
GROWTH OCCURS THE LEGISLATURE
CAN GET ADDITIONAL REPORTING ON
OUTCOMES- TO IN TO ASSESS THE
SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM. SECOND
I KNOW THAT WAS A LOT OF HAPPY
TO ELABORATE FURTHER IN THE Q.
AND A ON ON ANY OF THESE
MATTERS. ARMY JUST OF. THANK
YOU THE PANELISTS N. OUR I KNOW
THAT WERE REALLY RUNNING LIGHT
IN THE- THE VC SAID THEY'RE
GOING TO RESPOND TO COMMENTS
AND I KNOW THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
ONE SENATOR OF HIS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR PRIME AT THE VET
CENTERS ON HERE LET ME ASK THE
OTHER CENTERS ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY SENATOR MEANT. I JUST
WANTED TO ECHO- SOME OF WHAT
HAS BEEN SAID. I SUPPORT THE
THEORY OF YOU SEE PRIME BUT
IT'S REALLY HARD TO JUDGE THIS
FROM ANY KIND OF COST BENEFIT
STANDPOINT WITHOUT FOR
ADDITIONAL DATA ON HOW LONG
PEOPLE. ARE STAYING THESE TYPES
OF COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
TARGETED- WHAT THE SUCCESS RATE
IS UNLIKE WHY SO WITH THAT
GETTING THAT DATA THIS WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SENATOR TROUBLED. IN
THIS AD COMMENTS ON THAT END AS
WELL- TWO QUESTIONS HERE. ONE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHAT PROMPTED THE INCLUSION OF
NEW PRIME PROGRAMS- AT THIS
TIME AND NUMBER TWO IN THE UC
SHARE WHY THEY'RE NO CAN- NO
CONSIDERATION CONSISTENT
REPORTING ON PRIME OUTCOMES THE
UC COLLECT DATA FOR REPORTING
PRIME OUTCOMES. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL FIELD THE FIRST
PART AND THEN MY COLLEAGUES
FROM USED YOU CAN FOLLOW UP ON
THE DATA THAT THE UC'S ARE
PROPOSAL STEMS. FROM FROM TWO
AREAS REALLY ONE IS THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON. EQUITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION
BUT ALSO EQUITY IN PUBLIC
HEALTH HEALTH OUTCOMES THIS IS
A TARGETED APPROACH TO TRAIN.
OUR THROUGH THE PRIME PROGRAM
WHICH IS- PROVEN THROUGH
VARIOUS. TARGETED TARGETED WAYS
TO REACH SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY UNDER RESOURCE.
COMMUNITIES B. THE THIS PART OF
THE OTHER ORIGINS OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS THAT
THIS WAS A- ARE A PRIORITY FROM
THE UC. AND SO WE ARE
PROPOSING- OUR OWN VERSION
WHICH IS ALMOST IDENTICAL AND
IT'S ESSENTIALLY- THEY WERE
RECOGNIZING WE ARE WE ARE
TOGETHER WITH THE UC ON ON
PRIORITIZING THIS ISSUE. OF
GRADUATE MEDICAL MEDICAL
EDUCATION SO THAT. PEOPLE CAN
BE TRAINED AND THEN SERVE UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE- LAST YEAR THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET. PROVIDED A UC
RIVERSIDE ALSO IN THE FRESNO
AREA THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF
THAT INTEREST SO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER PIECE
HERE. THANK YOU SAVOR CANNON
FOR UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WHAT HAPPENED TO DEVELOP
METRICS FOR REPORTING ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE PRIME PROGRAMS
WE DON'T HAVE ALL OF THE DATA-
SUGGESTED BY THE L. A. O.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
TRACK OUR STUDENTS BY THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS AFTER
THEY GRADUATE- PLACEMENT DATA
IS. DEPENDENT ON US KNOWING
WHERE THEIR RESIDENCY WAS AND
THE STUDENTS SELF REPORTING BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF DATA THAT WE
COULD REPORT ON REGARDING OUR
GRADUATION RATES RETENTION
RATES OF WHO ISN'T WHO IS
ENROLLED IN THE PRIME PROGRAMS
AND WHERE THEY HAVE THEIR
RESIDENCY. OF PLACEMENT SO WE'D
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU OF
WHAT THE COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
DOC REPORT- I DO WANT TO ALSO
COMMENT THAT MEDICAL SCHOOLS
UNLIKE ALL OTHER GRADUATE
EDUCATION. I HAVE SEPARATE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS- WHERE
THE NUMBER OF ENROLLED STUDENTS
ARE IS ACTUALLY DIRECTED UP TO
THE SCHOOL AND HAS TO BE ON
THAT THOUGHT FEDERAL. NATIONAL
BOARD HAS TO BE NOTIFIED- OF
THE ENROLLMENT- INTENT OF THE
SCHOOL AND WE- MUST PROVE THAT
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO
CORRECT AND TAKE IN A CLASS AND
FULLY GRADUATE THAT CLASS
BEFORE WE CAN EVER ENROLL THEM.
SO THERE ARE SOME UNIQUE
REQUIREMENTS ON MEDICAL SCHOOLS
THAT DON'T EXIST FOR OTHER
TYPES. OF PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS
THANK YOU. THANK WANNA COME
THAT I A VERY MUCH OF THE PRO.
WE I ACTUALLY UCR'S ADDITION TO
MY DISTRICT AND SO I AM VERY
VERY PRIVY TO THE FACT THAT WE
ARE. HAVE A SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
DOCTORS- IN OUR IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND- SO I AM VERY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROGRAM- SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE IT. THE COMPLETE
YOUR QUESTIONS- AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOB WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ITEM SIX DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THERE'S
TWO COMPONENTS TO THIS ITEM ALL
INTRODUCED THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUE RANDY CAT SCAN IN A
DRASTIC QUALITY COMPONENT. SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS.
THIS IS IN RECOGNITION TO UC'S
BACKLOG OF NEED. SO ALL ALL OR
CALL ON MY COLLEAGUES RANDY
KATZ TO TAKE UP THE CAPITAL
ALLEY HE'S HERE. HELLO FROM
LARGER ANY CATS OF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. SO EACH ARM
EACH YEAR AS THE- WATSON NOTICE.
ON A FINANCE PRODUCES A LONER
PROMOTE AND FINAL LETTER. ALL
MUCH SHARE OF YOU SEE SUPPORT
BUDGET CAN BE FOR OUTLAY YOU
SEE SUBMITS THE REPORT EACH
SEPTEMBER THIS YEAR THERE'S
BEEN TWO- ONE IS AN
INFORMATIONAL REQUEST
REGARDING- YOU SEEM SAID
MEDICAL CENTER AND THE OTHER
ONE'S A SEISMIC. RETROFIT HE'S.
WE'RE OPEN FOR QUESTIONS AFTER
THE OTHERS HAVE GONE. WE. I
THINK THAT THE UC YOU'VE AHEAD-
THANK YOU CANNOT READY TO OF
CALIFORNIA- THE GOVERNOR
INVESTMENT OF HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY PROJECTS
THAT WILL ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY
TO ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES AND
INCREASED LOCAL EMPLOYMENT.
EVERY UC CAMPUS WILL RECEIVE A
PORTION OF THESE FUNDS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IDENTIFIED. FOR INTEGRATED
CAPITAL ASSET MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM OR I CAN'T THAT ARE
HIGH PRIORITY TO CAMPUSES OR
THAT CAN PROVIDE ENERGY
EFFICIENCIES WE ESTIMATE THAT
THESE PROJECTS CAN BE INITIATED
WITHIN SIX MONTHS AND THAT'S
PROVIDE LOCAL EMPLOYMENT THAT I
ALREADY REFERENCED- TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE COMMENTS IN THE
AGENDA THE UC REGENTS DID ASK
FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS.
WERE VERY GRATEFUL PART THE
GOVERNOR GAVE US- WE SELECTED
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
BASED ON THE PROJECTS THAT
COULD BE INITIATED WITHIN SIX
MONTHS SO IF THE LEGISLATURE
DID HAVE ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
DISTRIBUTE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THOSE AND GET GOING ON
THE PROJECTS VERY QUICKLY- WE
DON'T SEE ANY ISSUES WITH THE
REPORTING ON THE LIST OF
PROJECTS THAT WAS REQUESTED IN
THE AGENDA- AND IN TERMS OF-
EXISTING ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
PROJECTS THE UNIVERSITY HAS- WE
HAVE SOMETHING CALLED THE
CARBON NEUTRALITY INITIATIVE
WHICH SET THE GOAL FOR YOU SEE
TREMENDOUS ZERO GREENHOUSE
GASES FROM OUR BUILDINGS AND
VEHICLE FLEET BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. IN ALIGNMENT WITH THIS
GOAL THE CAMPUS FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANS HAVE BEGUN
TO PRESENT PROJECTS THAT
IMPROVE ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
PROMOTE CLEAN ENERGY- ALSO
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE YEARS
HE HAS BEEN A PARTNER WITH
CALIFORNIA UTILITIES DO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS ON OUR
CAMPUSES AND THROUGH THIS
PARTNERSHIP WE RECEIVED BETWEEN
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY DO
ENERGY UPGRADES ON OUR
CAMPUSES- AND WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO WE THINK THAT THE
MAINTENANCE IS YOU CAN USE OF
TIME FOR- WE RECOMMEND YOU
CONSIDER THE PURPOSE FUNDING
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE HAS
STARTING. OUT WE EVEN THINK I
YOU REVIEW OTHER ONE TIME
BUDGET PROPOSALS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR IF YOU FIND ANYTHING
THAT'S LOWER PRIORITY THIS
WOULD BE A GOOD CANDIDATE TO-
REDIRECT FUNDS AND FORTY
RECOVERY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
DOING SO WOULD HELP IMPROVE
BOTH UC'S AND THE STATE'S
BUDGET RESILIENCY IN THE COMING
YEARS. WE DO RECOMMEND ONE
MODIFICATION- TO THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE THAT AFFECTS THE
PROCESS OF ONE THAT PROJECTS TO
BE APPROVED. UNDER THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH PROJECTS. ARE IT WOULD
SUPPORT THIRTY DAYS AFTER THE
FUNDS ARE RELEASED. AND ARE
PROPOSED RECKON A MODIFICATION
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND GET
THIS LIST OF PROJECTS THREE
DAYS BEFORE THE FUNDS ARE
RELEASED THIS WOULD GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE TIME TO REVIEW THE
PROPOSED PROJECTS. AND IT'S
ALSO BE MORE CONSISTENT WITH
HOW THE STATE HAS FUNDED OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ARE NONE THE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M GOING TO
MOVE ON I NORMALLY WOULD HAVE
ASKED YOU A QUESTION BUT- WERE
GIVEN VERY SHORT TO APPRECIATE
THAT WILL NOT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL TRY TO
ADDRESS THEM BEFORE THE MAY
REVISE REMOVED ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN VARIOUS GOVERNMENT
PROPOSED. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES WELL
NEEDS VARIOUS PROPOSALS START
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET PROPOSES ONE MILLION ON
KEEPING GENERAL FUND FOR THE UC
TO ADOPT A COMMON LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT ALIGNS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DO SO BY THE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR ACADEMIC YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND OR CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. ARE YOU SEE
FACULTY AND THAT'S THE FOCUS
ON- ONLINE RELATED TECHNOLOGY
AN IMPROVING ONLINE LEARNING.
THE GOVERNOR'S ALSO PROPOSES
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND OR TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
SCIENCE AND INNOVATION THIS
WOULD PROVIDE STIPENDS FOR
STUDENTS OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD. AND FOSTER CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN. UNIVERSITY PROGRAMS
THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES AND
INDUSTRY EMPLOYERS SO THAT'S
GETTING TO REGARD BIGGER THEME
OF ALIGNING HIGHER EDUCATION
AND WORKFORCE. THE THERE ARE
TWO OTHER OPTIONS. THIS IS HERE
BOTHOF THESE NEXT ONES WERE
WERE ORIGINATED WITH THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT WE'RE
CALLING THEM OUT HERE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BECAUSE THAT
THE AMOUNTS ARE JUST SO THAT WE
CAN CLEARLY ANNOUNCED WHAT-
WHAT IS BEING BUDGET FROM
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. SO IMMIGRANT
LEGAL SERVICES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT IMMIGRANT LEGAL
SERVICES FOR FACULTY STAFF AND
ORIGINATED WITH THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT- SO DID THE
FIREARMS OF VIOLENCE RESEARCH.
IT INVESTMENT WHICH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I INCLUDES
ONE MILLION ON GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS THIS IS A UC DAVIS FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER SO
THAT CONCLUDES OUR OUR VARIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS. THAT THEY WERE
COMING TOGETHER HERE IN THE
AGENDA AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THOSE
PERFECT ARM UC. FAVOR CANNON
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE PEOPLE THAT
THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO INVEST IN
YOU SEE STUDENTS AND RESEARCH-
IF THE INTEREST OF TIME ALL TO
SAY WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THESE ITEMS. EXCEPT WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARM
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME ALL FOCUS MY
CONCERN MIGHT. ON THE LARGEST
PROPOSAL IN THIS ISSUE WHICH IS
THAT. CLOSE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR SCIENCE AND INNOVATION. AND
HERE WE HAVE A FEW CORE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL THE
FIRST IS BASED ON PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
UNIVERSITY AND HOW WOULD SPEND
THE FARMS. THE IMPACT SEEMS
LIKE IT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
VERY ON EURO SUPPORTING ABOUT
FIVE FIVE HUNDRED FORTY-
RESEARCHERS AND STUDENTS THAT
YOU SEE ANNUALLY OR TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED STICK-
INDIVIDUALS OVER THE FIVE YEAR
PERIOD. IN A NARROW SUBSET. OF
INDUSTRIES CALIFORNIA. OUR
SECOND IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
PROVIDED- A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS OF THE STATE WORKFORCE
NEEDS. AND ABSENT THAT BROADER
ANALYSIS IT'S DIFFICULT TO
GAUGE WHETHER ABOUT- PROPOSED
ACTIVITIES OPPOSE INDUSTRIES
THAT WOULD BE TARGETED WITH
THESE FARMS REFLECT THE STATE'S
HIGHEST WORKFORCE PRIORITIES.
AND IN THIRD THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS SIGNALED TO THE LEGISLATURE
THAT IT INTENDS TO SUBMIT
ANOTHER WORKFORCE PROPOSAL
TOTALING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. ANDREW THIS IS A
DIFFERENT PROPOSAL- THE
ADMINISTRATION STATES THAT IT'S
INTENT FOR HIS FORTHCOMING
PROPOSAL IS TO ALIGN HIGHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS WITH
WORKFORCE NEEDS THAT'S THE SAME
OBJECTIVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CITES FOR THIS
PROPOSAL THE LEGISLATURE HAS
LITTLE INFORMATION AS TO HOW
THESE PROPOSALS INTERACT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A FEW OPTIONS
FOR THIS PROPOSAL. ONE IS TO
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE A STRONGER PROPOSAL
THAT FROM BETTER JUSTIFIES WHY
IT'S PROPOSAL IS REFLECTING
AMONG THE STATE'S HIGHEST
WORKFORCE PRIORITIES.
ALTERNATELY LEGISLATURE CAN-
WITHHOLD MAKING A DECISION FOR
THIS- OTHER OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL.
REVIEW BOTH AS A PACKAGE AND
SEE HOW IT AND SEE HOW THEY
INTERACT AND SEE WHICH ONES
MIGHT BE THE- HIGHEST PRIORITY.
OR ALTERNATIVELY LEGISLATURE
COULD READ THIS BILL. IN
REDIRECT BOB FUNDING FOR OTHER
ONE PURCHASE AND- AS I KNOW
THAT THIS IS BE THE EXAM SORT
OF AND IN THE LAST ITEM.
CORRECT THE FUNDS FOR
SUPPORTING MORTGAGE FOR
MAINTENANCE. WHERE WILL THE
OBJECTIVES OF THE LOT EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND THEY WOULD BE MORE
CONNECTED TO ADDRESSING BUDGET
RESILIENCY FOR THE STATE AND
THE UNIVERSITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. OF THE SUB COMMITTEE
RECEIVED A CONCERN FROM A
STAKEHOLDER WITH CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LMS PROPOSAL BEING A NO BID
CONTRACT. GIVE ANY COMMENT ON
THAT. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BAKER CLERK AGAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE
WOULD KNOW THE PERSPECTIVES A
LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROPOSAL. IS
SPECIFIC TO A COMMON
INTERSEGMENT FOR LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT ALIGNS
WITH THE SYSTEM USED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
FOR CLARITY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUMMARY DOES SPECIFY
THAT CAMPUS IS THE LEARNING
MANAGEMENT PLATFORM THAT IS
USED BY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THE THANK YOUS OF A SINGLE
LEARNING MANAGEMENT PLATFORM AT
CREATIVE STREAMLINING AND
SAVINGS YEAH COMPANIES OF
SCALE. THE GOVERNOR'SBUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR YOU SEE AND ALSO
FOR CSU TO USE THE SAME COMMON
PLATFORM AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WHAT OFFER TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND OTHER STUDENTS TO
TAKE COURSES ACROSS MULTIPLE
CAMPUSES HAVE AN EASIER TIME
TRANSITIONING ACROSS
INSTITUTIONS AND FROM SEMESTER
TO SEMESTER. AND WE ALSO SEE IT
AS BENEFICIAL FOR THE SEGMENTS
BE ABLE TO FURTHER LEVERAGE
COST SAVINGS. ON THEIR CONTRACT
AND LYFT INPUT. OKAY WELL IT
JUST TO COME TO KEEP IN MIND
ANY. FROM SENATE MANNER CENTER
CHAU. SENATOR MEANT- YES I HAVE
A CALM AND I JUST FIRST WANT TO
APPLAUD. ALL OF YOU FOR THE
FUNDING FOR UC DAVIS'S FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER WHICH
IS THINK IS SO IMPORTANT I IT'S
A TRAVESTY THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT SUPPORT
RESEARCH INTO GUN VIOLENCE AND
THIS CAUSES ODYSSEUS- BEFORE
COVE IT WAS AN EPIDEMIC PROBLEM
AND- LOST IN THE NEWS- IN THIS
CUPBOARD PANDEMIC WAS THE FACT
THAT TWENTY TWENTY WAS ACTUALLY
THE MOST VIOLENT YEAR FOR GUN
VIOLENCE. I IN IN RECENT
DECADES AND SO I THIS IS THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE WHEN WE'RE NOT
GONNA GET A HANDLE ON IT AS
POLICYMAKERS WITHOUT DOING SOME
KIND OF RESEARCH SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
YOU SEE RELATED TO THE UC DAVIS
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES. AND
THAT IS I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF LEGAL SERVICES
OFFERED TO THE UC'S IF THIS IS
JUST A QUESTION OF
CLARIFICATION. ARE THERE
SERVICES FROM THIS PROGRAM
BEING OFFERED THIS YES USING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES AS
WELL. THANK YOU CERTAIN. AT
THIS. TIME THESE SERVICES ARE
FOR UC'S STUDENTS STAFF AND
FACULTY. OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT THAT I'M TOLD THAT THAT IS
A YEAH THAT THE CS USING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE EVEN
MORE DEMAND SO THIS IS GONNA BE
SUPER IMPORTANT- GOING FOR ME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF THAT COMPLETES
OUR ISSUES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. AND FOR
THOSE THAT WISH TO PUBLIC
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGH
THE BY TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
OH NINE- AND WILL BE LIMITING-
COMMENTS TWO ONE MINUTE. IT BUT
WE WANT TO OFFER A TESTIMONY TO
THE PEOPLE AND THE TWO HEARING
ROOMS AND SO WILL BEGIN ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES THAT WISH
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THIS ART. COMMITTEE ROOM.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE ANYBODY WANTED TO
MAKE COMMENTS AND ONE TWELVE.
WE SEE NO ONE ARE THERE- MISTER
MODERATOR OR MS MODERATOR WE
WILL GO TO THE- TELECONFERENCE
AND PLEASE LET US KNOW. HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE THERE ARE IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU- RIGHT NOW
YOU KNOW. ABOUT TWELVE PEOPLE
QUEUED UP AND OUR FIRST ONE
WILL COME FROM LINE TWENTY TWO
AND FOR EVERYBODY ELSE IN THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO MISTER
MODERATOR JUST BEFORE YOU BEGIN
THE NEW YEAR. I CAN HEAR YOU
JUST FINE BUT JUST BEFORE YOU
BEGAN I'VE A BRIEFING I'M
SUPPOSED TO DO ELEVEN THIRTY SO
I'M IN A STEP OUT OF THE
HEARING RETURN THE GAVEL OVER
TO SENATOR JOE BOWEN WHO WITH
THE ASSISTANCE OF SENATOR MEN.
ARE WILL BE HEARING FEE- THE
COMMENTS FROM YOU AND CLOSING
THE HEARING WHEN WE'RE DONE
WITH THE COMMENTS SO YOU CAN GO
TO- COMMENTER NUMBER ONE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
QUESTIONS AND WE'RE AT FIFTEEN
NOW AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CARLOS MARQUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION
THAT WE SUPPORT GOVERNOR SINCE
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE
PROGRESS TOWARD ESTABLISHING.
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM PROGRESS ON THE SYSTEM
TODAY IS PROMISING AND CONTINUE
AND CONTINUE HIS WORK IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE. THAT DATA AND SYSTEMS
COORDINATION IN PLACE TO CLOSE
THE OPPORTUNITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS FOR ALL CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS. WHILE
ABOUT THE RATIONING AND
OVERSIGHT IS CRITICAL IT CANNOT
RESULT IN THE DELAY EFFORTS TO
SYSTEM. CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
AN EFFECTIVE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM- REPRESENT
INVALUABLE TOOL FOR POLICY
MAKERS EDUCATORS AND THE
PUBLIC- OR AT AT MAKING
PROGRESS. TOWARD STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT THANK YOU. I THINK
VERY MUCH WE'LL HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER. TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I ONE HOLD HEARINGS. WE
CAN HEAR YOU YES WE CAN HEAR GO
AHEAD MA'AM. YEAH I'M MY NO ONE.
ON MONDAY OF UCSF. ELIMINATION
AND ALL- BECAUSE. THREE FOR.
HOME COALITION LIKE TO YOU CAN.
AND FOR- HUNDRED NINE. TWELVE
HUNDRED NINE MILLION AND THAT
BUDGET REQUEST BERNIE TRYING. I
HAD BEFORE THAT TRAINING AT THE
TRAINED THE STAFF THAT AND DOWN
FROM CHEN. AND OF TREATMENT
BECAUSE I CAN. AND MY MOM WHO
DIED OF CANCER AND HAVE THE TO
GET YOU TO WHERE YOU ARE HELLO
IF THE DOCTORS MORE CULTURE
COMPETENT WHICH MY MOM WOULD BE
ALIVE NOW- BECAUSE I'D GET THE
SPELLING. HOW STATION TO TROOPS.
FROM A BLACK WOMAN DOWN WITH
THEIR TRYING TO MATTERS BY BE
ABLE TO THAT MYSELF I AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUR TESTER YOU'RE
ONE MINUTE. THANK YOU. OKAY SO
IT. I WANT AND- THAT. EVEN
THOUGH THE- FINANCE MAY MAY NOT
THE TRUTH LIKE IT THAT THEIR-
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT THAT
THING VERY MUCH FOR SHARING
YOUR COM MA'AM. MODERATOR WILL
GO TO GOOGLE. TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU LIKE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF
THE CAL ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AND HEALTH THE- I'M HERE THE
MORNING AND SUPPORT YOU KEEP
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUICKER
EASY WELL THE NEXT ONE PLEASE.
THANK YOU WE WILL ALIGN THIRD
FOUR PER GO AHEAD. BUSH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR OPEN. WELL MY NAME
IS JOHN RIGHT I THINKING ON
ISSUE. TWO CAREER THE I. I KNOW
A GREAT STUDENT WILL BE
CALIFORNIA. I MADE A COMMENT
THAT I HAVE TO. WE TALKED YOU
JIMMY I DON'T WOULD EXPECT NEED
I BELONG TO OF THE LOWER RIGHT
STUDENT. A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION REQUIRED
AUTHORIZATION. EIGHTEEN AND
OVER WHAT WILL BE DONE INCLUDE
THE YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE- AT A
MINUTE. WOULD YOU MIND JUST
WRAPPING IT UP REALLY QUICK FOR
US THANK YOU. INITIALLY TRYING
TO ALL THE GOOD GUIDANCE FOR
STUDENTS. INCLUDING COLLEGES IN
YEARS THANK YOU CAN USE THE
SYSTEM THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE. THREE A
SUPPORTED EXTENSION OVER WHAT'S
GOING WORK OPPORTUNITIES THANK
YOU YOU'RE A GREAT SPEAKER
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY. WILL GO TO
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU OUR LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING NUMBER
TAYLOR WITH CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU EXPECTED SUPPORT FOR
ITEM NUMBER THREE REGARDING
RESTORATION OF THE FUNDING FOR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE REPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OVER THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE WILL LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY MEMBERS MANY RODRIGUEZ
EXTENSION TRACKS WHAT.
CONDITION ONE HE DOESN'T
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE FIFTEEN MILLION TO
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM WHICH ALLOWS THE STATE
TO PURSUE THE PHASE ONE OF THE
PROJECT. WE NEED TO DO IS BRING
FOR EQUITY BUT ALLOW THE STATE
TO SEE THE IMPACT OF EDUCATION
POLICY AND PROGRAMS ON STUDENTS
AS THEY MOVE THROUGH THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. AND NOW A
LOT OF VALUE AND STRENGTHEN
THOSE EFFORTS AS NEEDED THIS IS
CRITICAL AS YOU RECOVER FROM
THE ENDEMIC. WE ALSO AGREE WITH
ALLIE- ON THE NEED TO ADDRESS
GOVERNANCE OF THE SYSTEM THE
INSTITUTIONAL AND PUBLIC
INTEREST ABOUT ONE ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR WE- SUPPORT BOTH LOOKING
TO MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATIONS
FOR EMERGENCY STUDENT FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS AND MENTAL
HEALTH THE TECHNOLOGY. WE
APPRECIATE THINGS IN DETAIL
ABOUT HOW MENTAL HEALTH AND
TECHNOLOGY FUNDING WILL BE
SPLIT AND UTILIZED WHICH IS
AWFULLY VALUATION METRICS WHICH
SHOULD THE FUNDS REACH
STUDENTS. LASTLY WE APPRECIATE
THE EARLY CONQUERED A
CONVERSATION ON ACTUALLY MAKING
SURE HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AFTER
THE U. C. WE WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
SYSTEM DOES HEALTHY PET
PROGRAMS INTENDED FOR OUT WE
CAN CLOSE OUT MY. CHARM OUT OF
MINNEAPOLIS. SHE INCREASED BY
FOR. THE YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR. IN NEXT CALLER FOR.
THANK YOU A LINE FORTY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JOSH HE GONNA BE
OF THE CAMPAIGN COLLEGE UP. I'M
BUT COMMENT TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT. CRADLE
TO CAREER DAY AT THE TOP. OVER
THE LAST FIFTY ONE CALIFORNIA
INTO LEADERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
SEVEN GAMES IN THE EXTENSIVE
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS TO
DEVELOP THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM WHICH HAS RESULTED
IN A BOLD AND BEAUTIFUL PLAN
THAT WILL MOVE CALIFORNIA
FORWARD IN IMPROVING COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS. THE CURRENT
ENDEMIC AND THE DIFFICULTIES
MANY EDUCATORS AND STUDENTS ARE
PLACED EASILY ACCESS DATA ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES UNDERSCORE THE NEED TO
HAVE THAT THE THAT THAT THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THE LONG TERM IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND TO PREPARE
FOR FUTURE CRISES WE ENCOURAGE
POLICY MAKERS TO EMBRACE THE
VISION BUT HE'S LEADERSHIP
SUPPORT THIS MODEST INVESTMENT
CONSIDERING THE POTENTIAL
LASTING POSITIVE IMPACT ON
STUDENT LIFE AND THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO ADDRESS OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND MEET. FUTURE WORK
WORK THE PLAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE WERE LIKE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE KISSED
DEVON LIKE REPRESENTING
CHILDREN NOW BUT WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OFFICE
WORKED- PHASE ONE OF THE
GREATEST REVIEWS BUT SOME ALLOW
FAMILIES EDUCATORS CARE
PROVIDERS AND OTHERS TO BOTH
IMPROVE THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF
HIS NEEDS AS WELL AS IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF SERVICE
DELIVERY- I DON'T KNOW- ECHO
TOO MUCH WHAT OTHERS THOUGHT
ABOUT THIS BUT WE'RE
PARTICULARLY HEARTENED THAT-
THE PLAN PROPOSES TO ENSURE.
ONGOING EDUCATION IT DIDN'T
WORK OUT I WILL MAKE SURE THAT
PUBLIC AND EDUCATORS KNOW HOW
TO EFFECTIVELY USE THAT THAT'S
MORE THAN JUST BUILD IT AND
MOVE ON FROM THAT- THIS
PROPOSED APPROPRIATION THE
MONSTER CAROL BRODIE CROFT
AGAINST CALIFORNIA'S TWO
HUNDRED. BILLION DOLLARS STATE
BUDGET BUT CAN YIELD LASTING
POSITIVE IMPROVEMENT ON THE
IMPACT ON STUDENT BORROWERS WHO
ENCOURAGED ME TO EMBRACE. YOU
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET ITEM THANKS
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
GO LIVE TWENTY SO PLEASE AHEAD-
YOU YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS ALEC
COLLECTIVE NAME FROM THE PALM
OF THE END OF. THE END OF
DANIELLE I'M A THIRD YEAR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE PHD
STUDENT OR A THIRD OF THE
PRESIDENT BUT IF THIS NATION OF
NATIVE AMERICAN MEDICAL STUDENT
AT UC SAN DIEGO I'M CALLING TO
ASK THAT YOU PRAY OR TYPE OF
EQUITY AND WORKFORCE DIVERSITY
AND SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR SPOKE
ABOUT HER QUEST FOR YOU. HI I
AM THE FIRST CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TO EVER ATTEND UC SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE MY FATHER
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST CALIFORNIA
INDIAN FABRIC BECOME A POSITION
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND A
THIRD DESCRIBE HELP HER NEED
FOR TWENTY YEARS. EARLY
NINETEEN DEMANDS TRANSFORMATIVE
ACTION THERE IS NO CRIME
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON THE HELP YOU
TO CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE
STAPLED AMBITIONS WERE NOT
HEALTHCARE EQUITY REQUIRE MORE
DOCTORS I AM SPECIALIZED
TRAINING WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUESTS FOR
PRIME AT THE PORT OF HIS
APOLOGY TO CALIFORNIA INDIAN
PEOPLE AND THE UNIVERSITY'S.
LAND GRANT MISSION. THANK YOU.
CONGRATS ON EFFORTS. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WE
WILL ALIGN THIRTY THREE PER GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS COMMENTING ON
BEHALF OF THE U. A. W. TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE REPRESENTING
OVER NINETEEN THOUSAND ACADEMIC
STUDENT EMPLOYEES. AND YOUR W.
FIFTY EIGHT TEN REPRESENTING
OVER TWELVE THOUSAND POSTDOCS
AND ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS AT UC.
JOHN STATE SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET VITAL RESTRAINT THAN
UNIVERSITIES RESEARCH MISSION
FOR CONTINUING TO DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND DELIVERING ON THE
UNIVERSITY'S EQUITY GOALS. OUR
MEMBERS ARE BETTER ABLE TO
PERFORM THE UNIVERSITY'S
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION MISSION
WITH INCREASED COMPENSATION
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT
UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITY.
NEAR THE B. TWENTY SIXTY FIVE
AND FIFTY AND- THE PORT OF.
HOUSTON SUCH A PRIORITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I.
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS I MEAN THAT
THE ENTERTAINMENT IN YOUR
MEDICAL CARE NO CRIME EVEN GET
THAT CALLING AT THE PORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE FROM
MULTICULTURAL BLACK WOMAN AND A
FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREA UP IN
CALIFORNIA AND I CHOSE CRIME
BECAUSE THERE'S LITERALLY NO
OTHER MEDICAL PROGRAM LIKE IT.
THEY CAN PREPARE MEDICAL
STUDENTS TO BE POSITIONED
LEADERS AND HEALTH EQUITY AND
BUILD CAPACITY FOR LIKE BANKERS
AND POLICY RESEARCH AND
COMMUNITY WORK IN CALIFORNIA
NEVADA POPULATIONS AND REDUCE
ISOLATION OF THAT COLOR FEEL IN
THE MEDICAL FIELD. I WOULD BEEN
IMPRIME CONDUCTING PEOPLE PLAN
TO RETHINK THEM IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION MY MENTOR IN PRIME
ALANIS IN FACT NUMBER THESE
PROJECTS INCLUDE BUILDING
MANAGER KIRK MENTORING OTHER
PROGRAMS WILL CONNECT YOU TO
NATIONAL REACH ALONG YOUR BACK
KNEE WC THANK THE ROLAND
RECENTLY RECRUITED OVER A
HUNDRED EIGHTY UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY STUDENTS TO TRY TO
WORK. IT WAS ALSO MEANT
BUILDING LASTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
CORPORATE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
OF OUR COMMUNITY CRIME AND SO
PART OF MY MEDICAL EDUCATION
AND I WANT NOTHING MORE THAN TO
TAKE WHAT I'VE LEARNED JUST
AREN'T MY HOMETOWN OF OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA. AMERICAN MEDICINE
THE PRIMARY CARE TO CONTINUE
CONTRIBUTE TO ENDING UP IN
CALIFORNIA BUT TODAY I ASK YOU
TO PLEASE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST FOR
TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION. THE
POSITION WORK WORK OUT WHEN YOU
DO BETTER THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR CALL WE'LL
HAVE THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CARMEN AND CRIMINAL
ANYTHING DURING TIME I STARTED
AND I MET LOT OF NEW PEOPLE I
ALSO KNOW THAT THE HOW THE
PANDEMIC AMPLE THE ISSUE IS
THERE A PARTICULAR WELL AT YOUR
WHERE STUDENTS HER IN THE
LEARNING HIGH OR IN TENSION
BECAUSE OF THE DECREE COSTS.
FOR THEM ARE MEANT TO HELP
POLICE ARE STRAINED A POWER
WHEN THEY'RE MOST NEEDED THERE
WE NEED A CALIFORNIA STATE I TO
PRIORITIZE STUDENTS WILL BEING
DURING THESE TIMES BY.
INCREASING THE USE THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYTHING
ELSE. RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
CALLING WE'LL HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS ARE NOT AVAILABLE
AT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
ITEM THE PROPOSED INVESTMENT
WILL ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS CRITICAL TOOL AND HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY INVOLVED THROUGHOUT
THE WORK GROUP PLANNING PROCESS
ENSURING THAT THE INTEGRATION
OF DATA PUBLIC SPEAKING
TRANSPARENT SECURE AND THAT
INCLUDES THE ADULT LEARNER AND
WORKER VOICE UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS ARE FACING
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND THAT
THAT. WILL BE A TOOL TO PROVIDE
THEM ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES WHILE ALSO HELPING
RESEARCHERS AND POLICY MAKERS
UNDERSTAND IDENTIFY DISPARITY
WITHIN THE EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE INSTANCE WE ALSO WANT
TO ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE BY THE LED- REGARDING THE
STRUCTURE OF THE GOVERNING
BOARD AND WE WOULD ALSO URGE
YOU INCREASE THE PUBLIC
MEMBERSHIP TO ADDRESS THE
IMBALANCE OF THE REPRESENTATION
I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF
THE WEST FIFTEEN WORK GROUP
MEMBERS AND THE STAKEHOLDER
PARTNERS AND GETTING US THIS
FAR. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE WILL TO. LAW FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KAREN HOBBY AND I'M A FIRST
GENERATION MEDICAL STUDENT
CALLING ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. I'M IN MY FIRST YEAR AND
UCSF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PRIME
PROGRAM ALSO CALLED AS TV PRIME.
A TV PRIME BROKERS MEDICAL
STUDENTS LIKE ME TO PRACTICE
MEDICINE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHICH CURRENTLY HAS THE LOWEST
APPLIED PHYSICIANS IN THE
STATE. AND I'M CALLING TO ASK
THAT YOU PRIORITIZE HOLD
ACCORDION WORK FORCE THEY WERE
HIT BY ADVERSITY TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST OF
TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR YOU. I WAS INSPIRED
TO JOIN US TO BE PRIME. BECAUSE
I EXPERIENCED HEALTH
DISPARITIES FIRSTHAND WHILE
GROWING UP IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND RESPECTED. I THOUGHT
THE ONLY MEMBERS ACROSS THE WAY
FROM PREVENTABLE CAUSES BECAUSE
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO SEE A
DOCTOR. I MYSELF NEVER WENT TO
THE DOCTOR BECAUSE WAIT TIMES
ARE MONTHS LONG. FOR ME JOINING
US TAKE THE TIME IS ABOUT
TAKING OWNERSHIP OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAS MADE ME THE
PERSON I AM TODAY. AND I WANT
TO GIVE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA HIGH
QUALITY HEALTH CARE THEY
DESERVE. IN NINETEEN HAD ONLY
REINFORCED HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN OUR STATE AND IT'S EXPOSED
THE DIRE NEED TO PROVIDE MORE
DOCTORS WHO ARE UNIQUELY
EQUIPPED TO COMBAT THE
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE. IN THE
UNDER REIMBURSEMENT FOR ABOUT
ONE MINUTE THANK YOU VERY
IMPORTANT GOVERNMENT. BUDGET
REQUEST OF TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR UC PRIDE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
IN A CARING FOR YOUR COMMUNITY.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MANY MIDDLE OF THE
COST AND AFFECT YOUR MEDICAL
STUDENT YES YES I'VE BEEN
CRYING UNDER URBAN UNDERSERVED.
I'M CALLING BECAUSE I HAD THE
UNIQUE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING IN
THE KEYBOARD MEDICAL SCHOOL IN
THE COMMITTEE WHICH I GREW UP
BUT ALSO. IN AN AREA THAT IT
DOES WORK DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY COLD THE NINETEENTH
WHICH IS A GOOD VISITATION
VALLEY IN THE BABY WITH A HIGH
RISK HOLD IT. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE REASON WHY I KEPT
CRYING IS IN ORDER TO GIVE
MYELF. A TOOL THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE BUT ALSO
THEIR COMMUNITY THAT DOES NOT
FEEL UNIQUE SERVICE SUPPORTED
BY. HOW THE CITY- I HAVE A
PRETTY EXPERIENCE MY OWN. HAVE
TO GATHER BOTH AT TRANSLATOR
TENNIS. AND ASKED LOOK WHO HAD.
ACCESS I. NOW I'M NOT. THAT THE-
BUT THE FINISHED PIECE OF.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE BECAUSE WHAT
THEY COVER GOVERNOR FAUBUS.
HOPE NINE MILLION. REQUEST FOR
EASY RIGHT TO GET. THANK YOU
VERY. FOR CALLING. MAY CALL IT.
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S NORA FINANCE
BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES I'M CALLING IT THE
POOR OF THE CREDIBILITY OF YOUR
DATE AT THIS TIME WE KNOW THAT
THE LOCKING ACTED IN SO HAVE
AMONG THE LOWEST EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND UPPER KEEPING
GAP AT THE RESULT HAVING THE
DATA ON WHERE WE ARE FAILING
OUR STUDENTS WILL HELP US
CORRECT EDUCATIONAL RACIAL
INEQUALITY THAT EXISTS IN THE
STATE WE ARE DISAPPOINTED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING OUR CENTERS OF CHILLED
BOWL AND THEN HE AND WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE
DEVELOPING THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM HAVING PARTICIPATED
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF LIGHT TO
THE K. TWELVE DATA SYSTEMS
HAVING RELIED ON DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COAST SECONDARY
EDUCATION COMMISSION BEFORE IT
WAS DISBANDED. AND NOW IS A
MEMBER OF ONE OF THE TWO
ADVISORY GROUPS TO THE DATA
WORK GROUP WE CANNOT EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
FLOWERS MARCOUSSIS AND
TRANSPARENT ANY DATA SYSTEM WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED YOUR SUPPORT
IS CRITICAL MORE SO BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC PUBLIC ADVOCATES
BELIEVE THIS SYSTEM WILL
INCREASE THE UTILITY OF
INFORMATION BY LOW INCOME AND
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. SO THEY CAN MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS AND THEIR
EDUCATION AND CAREER PATHS AND
BY POLICY MAKERS SO THEY CAN
EVALUATE AND MAKE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENTS WE CONCUR WITH
ELLY ELLS RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
BALANCING THE GOVERNING BOARD
BETWEEN DATA PROVIDERS AND THE
PUBLIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JUST ABOUT EVERYONE
ONE MINUTE THAT. WAS PERFECT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO NAME IS AMANDA CROW AND
PROUD YOU THINKING TRYING I
GRADUATED YOU KNOW NINE A
DEGREE BY AND I'M CURRENTLY
WRAPPING UP MY FIRST QUARTER OF
DOCTORAL STUDIES IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP AT UC SAN DIEGO. I'M
HERE TODAY TO URGE LAWMAKERS TO
RESTORE FUNDING CUTS TO UC THE
FIRST GENERATION WOMEN OF COLOR
I KNOW THAT MY YOUTH EDUCATION
IS MORE THAN A DEGREE ON MY
WALL. ACCESS OPPORTUNITY AND
EQUALITY THE GENERATIONS TO
COME INCLUDING MY DAUGHTER MY
COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE I'VE YET
TO MEET RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
INCREASED RESOURCES SUCH AS
FUNDING HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON STUDENTS ABILITY TO
DRIVE THE SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE
THEIR POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
I'M CALLING TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT RESTORING CRITICAL
FUNDING FOR YOU SEE IN THE
STATE BUDGET I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE PROPOSAL ANNOUNCED BY
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP THE
GOVERNOR THAT WAS FULLY START
PACKING ATC I HOPE THAT YOU
SUPPORT PROPOSAL AND BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE FIFTY
SIX GO AHEAD. MY YOU ARE OPEN.
THIRTY SIX ARE YOU MUTED. MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
THIS IS THAT WE HAVE. SORRY
THERE HI THERE THANKS SO MUCH
MY NAME IS MONICA AND I'M
CALLING IN FOR ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE FORTY BTC PRICE PROGRAM
I'M I'M A GRADUATE OF THE
INAUGURAL UCSF PRIME PROGRAM
I'M THE DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANTS
IN THE FIRST MY FAMILY. COOL
COOL I'M CURRENTLY AN ASSOCIATE
CLINICAL PROFESSOR FAMILY
MEDICINE AT UCSF AND HONORED TO
BE A MEDICAL MEDICAL EDUCATOR
IN THE INSTITUTION RIGHT
TRAINED FOR MANY YEARS AGO I'M
CALLING TO ASK YOU TO
PRIORITIZE HEALTH EQUITY
HEALTHCARE ACCESS. AND
WORKFORCE DIVERSITY THE COURT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST
FOR YOU THE CRIME I CAN SAY
WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT YOU KEEP
PRIME PREPARED ME AND MY FELLOW
GRADUATES TO PRACTICE MEDICINE
IN HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
AND UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITY.
I'M A FAMILY TRADITION AND
FACULTY MEMBER CURRENTLY MY
AREA IS HIV MEDICINE AND I'M
ALSO INVOLVED IN NUMEROUS
RELATED ANTI RACISM AND HEALTH
EQUITY INITIATIVE- I EVERY
SINGLE PRIME GRADUATE- THAT I
KEEP IN TOUCH AND WE'LL TELL
YOU THE SAME THING THAT WE
WITHOUT A DOUBT- ARE THE
PHYSICIAN LEADERS THAT WE ARE
TODAY. IN THESE AREAS BECAUSE
OF THE ROBUST TRAINING
MENTORSHIP AND SPONSORSHIP AND
FINANCIAL AID THAT WE RECEIVE
FROM THE PRIME PROGRAM. MY
FELLOW GRADUATE THURMAN MIGHT
HEAR THE DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION IN THEIR DEPARTMENT-
THEY'RE PROVIDING FRONTLINE
PRIMARY CARE AND EMERGENCY CARE
TO UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES
DURING THE PANDEMIC- AND KNOW
THAT ONE OF US WILL BE HERE ARE
ACTIVELY MAKING SPECIALTY CARE
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO MARGINAL IF
NEED BE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YEAH I KNOW I NEED TO WRAP UP
AND- THANK YOU. YOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY-
MODERATED HAVE ANY. OTHER
CALLERS. IN THE QUEUE. NO OTHER
ARE UP AT THIS TIME MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HAVE YOU
HEARD FROM ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC SENATORS ARE SENATOR
MAN DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
IF YOU WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING
THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE IS
ADJOURNED. THE GERMAN DOES
CONCLUDE OUR CONFERENCE FOR
TODAY THANK YOU.